And again, I would basically yell because, you know, just like
out of instinct of trying to get a point across or even sometimes
just tell a joke. And the way that she would handle it is she
>> he yells to deliver his jokes. That's uh >> who
would feel hurt and scared. >> You I can kick you the out
of here for what the you've done to me. You've destroyed me.
>> What? How? All I ever want to do is >> stop lying
to me for once. Look at me in the eyes and stop lying to me.
like uh rwording people is natural and necessary for a happy
and healthy society. You >> look at me and accept what
you have done to me. Then you say what I you me you promised
me everything. You lied to me.
>> Look at me. I said stay again. Look at me. Tell me.
Tell me. Tell me what the you just said. Tell me.
>> We We can do this. You know what? I I just I saw Sam
Alman and I'm like, "Never mind. Never mind. Never mind." Brad
Tasting Music. Brad Tasting Music. We've never done this content
before on this stream.
I found a video. This guy, it's got a 3.4K view video. That's
like the timeline for Brad Taste of Music. I do want to actually
go figure that out because some of this stuff is very funny.
If you guys don't know who Brad Taste of Music is, he's a fairly
big YouTube uh music reviewer,
okay? Big- time music reviewer on YouTube. He recently had a
he recently like pseudo retired or was going to take time off
he'd gotten into a big drama with like his uh partner and he
was going to take time off and then instead of taking time off
he decided to just like come back and sort of like drop a video
on his partner who had maybe who kind of let him off with like
lightly from their relationship cuz he had some bad behaviors
and then he made a video on her and she appears to have leaked
some audio of one of their fights which apparently paints him
in a terrible light. I didn't listen to it. Okay. I have not
heard this audio yet. I have not heard this audio. No spoilers.
I've heard it's crazy, though. Why does Sam Alman look like Todd
Howard? I have no idea.
So, where's his freestyle? Wait, which one is Is this freestyle
one of these videos? Hold on. Let me give me a second here. Is
his freestyle one of these videos? Cuz I feel like possibly one
of these videos like that. Is this his freestyle right here?
Yeah, this would be like his freestyle, right? 48 minutes. This
video. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This is it for sure. Okay.
All right. We got all that stuff. We got the the audio leak.
We got his first my statement. So, what we'll do is we'll watch
the history video that I just pulled up until we get to basically
his one-year retirement that he planned and then we'll switch
over. Okay. >> The music keeps digging himself a deeper
hole. Going from a small music reviewer who garnered a cultlike
following to now a local cow in the music scene. something him
and his exartner wanted to avoid at all costs. Happy hump day.
Welcome back to the second channel where we sloppily cover music
news and drama. Today we're yapping about Brad Taste of Music
who needs no introduction. I'm assuming you already know the
fella, so I'm not going to break down his history for you. There's
plenty of other videos that do that. My mission here today is
to give you all the drama, all the lore, uh, in kind of a timeline
format because it there's so much that went down, especially
recently.
That's exactly what I want. I That's all I want in the whole
world. A timeline formatted video going through Brad's career
and his drama >> that it's now hard to keep up. Ladies,
gentlemen, they >> I believe he paused content creation
to go to rehab for a weed addiction.
For a weed addiction. A weed addiction. >> Ladies and g
This is going to be a long one. Sit back, relax, and please keep
in mind I'm going to give you surface level information. I know
uh the length of the video doesn't seem that way, but trust me,
it's all surface level [__] Every single drama I
touch on has an entire rabbit hole of its own that whatever you
enjoy, you can go research on your own. I'm sure again there's
probably videos on that. Uh the Brad universe is insane. But
today, uh we're going to start in July of 2024. This is where
it all
decided to post. >> Oh yes, sorry. This was supposed to
be my intro. Brad Taste, if you don't remember, is the guy who
took pictures with Ethan and Eel Klein and then he got bullied
by his leftist friends and he disavowed them. Do you guys remember
this is my biggest tweet on my entire timeline.
I'm pretty sure. I think this is my biggest tweet on my entire
timeline was this one. Members of my family have died at the
hands of a It was honestly It has honestly made one of this one
of the hardest situations I've ever been presented. I understand
why people are upset. I want to make it very clear that I stand
with the people of
>> He disavowed he disavowed Ethan and Ela
>> Oh, what is this? Yeah, man. It sure is. Thank you for
the gifted sub. My grandma got killed recently. I was pretty
bummed about it. But I think was probably more happy she's dead
than I am sad to lose her. The total happiness in the world increased.
So whatever. The blood coming out. Yeah, that was Brad. That
was Brad Taste.
That's the guy. That's the guy we're covering now. This is so
long ago. This is when I first started streaming. This is over
a year ago. Oh, never mind. It's like over a year ago still though.
Long time. >> Photos on Twitter. And as you can see, uh,
he's replying to this tweet with an apology. Now, if you don't
know, this is Hila and Ethan Klein of the H3 podcast. I'm sure
you do know. And there's not that much engagement with this post.
There's only 58 comments, but for some reason, Brad decided to
uh apologize for these photos. The caption read, "This image
made a statement that I did not intend to make, and I'd like
to apologize for people who were hurt or upset by this. I also
apologize for my quick response as it was dismissive toward people
who care about me and others deeply. I appreciate you looking
out for me." Now, the context. Why is I think this might have
been one of the first times that Ethan became like unhinged,
too. Like, they they were so that Brad like disavowed them out
of nowhere. They were so mad. It was very goofy. Oh, hold on.
>> He apologizing for uh taking photos with the H3 podcast.
Well, Brad Tace is open about his politics, which there's nothing
wrong with. Uh but what happened was he he attracted an extremely
left crowd. Again, nothing wrong with that. And there's a narrative
going around that Ethan and Hila Klein are Zionists, which I
personally don't believe is true. I think the reason why people
think that is because uh Ethan was >> uh Hila is absolut
I feel like Hila is like an unapologetic Zionist. Isn't she?
I don't know if Ethan is for sure, but Hila
Hila 100% is
>> about innocent Israelis dying and him being and his
wife being Israeli. Obviously, they have a personal emotional
attachment to everything that's going on. But people kind of
took that and ran with it as if he's not pro Palestine, which
he is. I'm pretty sure his take is I'm pro Palestine. >> I
don't think he is like a bloodthirsty Zionist. She's not like
a like hardcore ethnationalist or something, but she's like a
Zionist for sure she is. Israel are the bad guys here, but I
think Israel should keep existing uh with peace and innocent
people from both sides shouldn't be dying. Also, I I apologize.
I'm reading directly from my script because I want to try to
avoid as many ups as I can. I'm not trying to spend too much
time in the editing room today. But anyway, Brad post this. Do
you see that guy who people tried to cancel him by making up
fake vids, AI vids of him saying the but then real footage of
him leaked actually saying slurs? No, but it sounds like he was
getting blackmailed with that real footage and tried to muddy
the waters, right? He tried to flood the zone with videos. Bold
Gambit seems to have failed >> as people are hitting him.
He's like, "What the heck?" And then immediately
>> What the heck? And taking the photos and just deletes
the post entirely. Now, that alone silly as Okay, all he had
to do was ignore it. But ladies and gentlemen, I introduce you
to the first domino to this hot mess. Now, after apologizing,
he decided to backpedal after seeing that Ethan Klein took it
to Instagram and he was upset. Now, here's Ethan's Instagram
stories. You can go ahead and pause and just read the whole thing
if you'd like, but basically was like, "What the?" All he did
was take a picture and now he apologized for taking a picture
and this [__] was crazy. So, what Brad did was just
basically say, "Hey, man. Listen, I shouldn't have apologized."
You know what, Ethan? >> Uh, I've never played any of the
Mass Effect games. Just get that out of the way now. Captain
C319.
Uh, never played Mass Effect game. I I want to say maybe I've
played a little bit of one of them, but no, never played a Mass
Effect game. Yeah, I think I don't know if the first one was
on Steam. I I didn't really play PC games at the time. Yeah.
>> Or I didn't play single player games. I played multiplayer
games. >> They're good people. and he even went on the
H3 podcast to have a conversation uh with E Ethan Klein. It was
a 10-minute conversation and the whole thing is just Brad absolutely
glazing H3 here just apologizing to Ethan and admitting that
uh he just reacted in a panic state because keep in mind at this
point Brad is not getting uh sorry Brad is not used to getting
so much hate on the internet cuz he's just a wholesome music
reviewer man that charges you $9 per minute for uh song requests
with a $10 minimum which is going to be relevant in a little
bit I promise. So yeah, he apologized to Ethan. He admitted he
was just bending the knee for the ter terminally online folk
on Twitter. Dude, the best part about Brad taste in music is
that lyrics literally saw this lyrics, the guy who used to be
a commentary YouTuber, literally saw how easy the money was from
Brad and was like, "Oh, I could do that." And then he built a
massive channel doing like basically the exact same thing. Like
unironically, within like a year, he just has like a channel
that's as big doing the same thing. That's like the funniest
part of the Brad Taste thing was Lar saw it and was like, "Oh,
that seems really easy." And then he started doing it >> and
it [__] twice because at first it was just little
hate. I showed you guys engagement wasn't that much. He could
have just ignored everything. It would be fine. But because he
apologized for the photo, uh he got even more hate for that apology
and it attracted more people and then backpedaling that
>> Then in the ultimate twist of irony, he ended up picking
up an audience that hated his previous character character caricature,
whatever his previous persona so much that they constantly sh
him for it, right? Like he's got the most trigger the most triggered
audience ever now. I don't know why. Apparently people who pay
you to listen to music for them not a very resilient people.
>> You just got him into deeper. But this is just the tip
of the iceberg because this snowballs so bad that this morning
again, I don't know if it's this morning or last night. Uh I
think it was this morning, but there was audio leaked of him
yelling at his now ex- fiance and uh just disrupted the guy.
But more on that later. By the way, join the Discord because
it's filled with people like you and I who are into cool music
and gaming. Link in description. But during this whole thing,
right before this call, I know I said I would give it to you
guys in timeline order, but everything's just kind of mixed up
here. here. So, to avoid confusion,
>> how fast are this going? 1.5. >> On to story number
two. Rad decided to platform Rose Malay. Now, why is Shy crying?
What's going on? What's the waterworks from? Well, the TLDDR
here is she's a weirdo. She said some uh questionable on Twitter
like uh Rwording people is natural and necessary for a happy
and healthy society.
Dude, I forgot Rose Malay was involved.
I think Rose Malay was like actually critical in the first Brad
Taste
if I if I don't miss my mark. >> She literally says right
here, consent is stupid. And then another tweet, I don't understand
why it's illegal for a dog to lick my when gay men uh each other's
asses all the time and this the Twitter logo thing is blocking
it. But she is proiality or was. I guess you can't make this
[__] up. You really can't. And I don't know if she's
just trying to be edgy and rage bait or this is a genuine opinion,
but there's another tweet that I couldn't find uh where she continues
to defend rworders. Now, what does all of this have to do with
Brad? Well, Brad decided to platform her. So, Brad and Rose have
been friends for a very, very long time. And he basically did
this community tab post where he's like, "Guys, go check out
Rose Malay. She's super cool, right?" Uh, and and I guess she
does. >> Go check out Brutus, tweeted Caesar. Go check
out this Brutus guy. It's pretty >> Does like music related
content. It's hard to say. I want to say she does music related.
Like I listen to every bad sample to find the worst, right? But
then 100 hours locked in a basement. Mr. Beast parody, but for
obvious reasons, people did not enjoy Brad platforming rose.
Uh and again, this was in the midst of the whole H3 thing. So
the timing, it's just absolutely terrible. Now, I feel like he
should have learned from the H3 thing. Okay, I feel like uh he
already did the promotion. He could have just deleted it silently,
not said anything, ignored it. But no, because what does our
protagonist Brad Taste of Music do after the backlash? Well,
he defended her. She is incredibly traumatized and likely mentally
ill. She isn't a monster, just someone who really needs attention
and will say some really messed up to get it. She knows this.
She's trying to learn from it and grow. Bradley, what the actual
are you doing right now? Defending someone who has gone off the
deep end because they have never had someone advocate for them.
Brother, no one has advocated for her because of the she said.
Are you insane? Who the [__] would advocate for someone
like that? But then he backpedals again. And again, you could
just pause it. I'm just scrolling through it. You can read the
whole thing yourself. But the TLDDR is he >> what? Sorry
for platinum forming Rose Malay. I really wanted to believe this
person could change. I saw my own mental disability in this person,
but they have said the some of the most awful
and evil stuff I've ever heard or seen heard and seen. There's
no room to be promoting someone like that here. I did not know
about the essay stuff. I just assumed it was a big in a big pile
of stuff I ignored from the first from this person or sorry about
this person the first time I forgave them. Deep down I didn't
want to believe what I was being told. >> Pause it. >> Maybe
I thought maybe if I I thought maybe if promoted something productive
they did. If I I guess promoted something productive they did,
they would change >> through it. You can read. >> Once
I was made aware of everything she has done, I should have take
immediately taken down the post and made it clear how I feel
about her actions. Instead, I attacked people who were trying
to help me. Misrepresented my views uh and misrepresented my
views disastrously. Sorry to my community for being grossly
Sorry to my community for being grossly negligent and self-destructive.
Sorry to my audience who got dragged into this. I know this has
reflected poorly on me and the people around me. But the TLDDR
is he claims that he didn't know about her saying the essay stuff
and he's just sorry for platforming her. Which leads us back
to this video of her crying. The video is titled regarding the
Brad situation. And what she's yapping about here is how she
made a mistake by tweeting those horrific things and she's just
trying to change but people aren't letting those tweets go and
she's pulling the whole like for me I'm a victim card and she's
just basically saying how her life is over and she has no faith
in humanity because people aren't open to change and growth.
But this isn't one of those situations where you said the end
10 years ago in private or even in public. This is a situation
where you allegedly self snitched about doing gross [__]
with your dog and uh are empathetic towards our >> Just
say it was a joke. Just say it was like a joke. Just say it was
a me is Mimi Edge posting. I don't >> words. But she follows
up this crying video with this video here. Brad taste rose report.
And this is basically an expose on Brad. And I think the first
like few seconds you you get like a a good idea of what it's
about. >> They were trans. I was so >> dude. What
the Brad tasted music? Look at that jawline. God damn. This guy
was looking good. More like Chad tasted music. I was so wrapped
up in my own that I was just like, I don't care about your gender
and hey, you're I mean, my god, I didn't even not realize that
word had been on an island and isolated and you couldn't say
it anymore. I said it in aing awful context, too. I was transphobic
at 17. I like Trump at 17. Rose remembers. I can tell you for
sure that I've said the nword, bro, you guys already knew this.
Come on. Oh my god. I know it's terrible. You guys are acting
like you've never said something you weren't supposed to say
before. Come on, chill. He released an album last year as like
Big Baller Beer and like he uses the N word. >> There's
nothing more sketchy than a white person who says they'd never
said the N word before. Okay. Never forgot what our relevant
taught us. That's that
you're you're completely full of if you refuse to admit that
you've said the N before.
You can't possibly be more full
>> So yeah, you get what this is. But she does mention
that uh Brad is lying about the apology for platforming her because
he did know about the essay tweets as he replied to them. She
also mentioned that he supposedly hates the audience he's
>> No, everyone has said it. Brazilian lad.
uh hi, how's it going? What's going on? >> Hello.
Uh we're talking about white people saying they had bad taste
of music and yeah, it's interesting interesting stuff. >> One
second here. Yep. Yep, yep, yep, yep. So, I just need to set
up the
>> You should be sorry. >> Oh, did I? I messed up,
didn't I? Oh, maybe not. Oh, I did. Sorry, guys. I'm setting
up avatars. Give me two seconds.
>> One Mississippi. >> Good to go. >> Two Mississippi.
>> Yeah. Good. Good to go. Good to go. Good to go. Good
to go. All right. >> He's sees them as numbers. >> Uh,
have you been listening to the video, by the way? >> Yeah,
I have. I'm surprised Rose Malay has something to do with this.
I forgot that Rose Malay was involved. Yeah, I totally forgot
about that. Crazy stuff. All right, here we go. >> Not
really people. The whole video is just a hit piece on criticizing
his character and past while also making herself look pretty
bad. Okay, because how are you crying about Brad not standing
up for you? But in this expose, you mentioned like you called
him out back in 2017. And half of this video is footage of this
interview. Like this is an interview recorded in November of
2020, right? This whole thing happened last year. Okay. And and
half of the footage of this video is this interview. I don't
know what the [__] the interview is about, but it's
literally Rose and this random ass dude. I don't even know who
the [__] he is. Straight up just talking [__]
about Brat. Oh my god, I'm so upset that the guy I talked [__]
about and even recorded an entire interview of talking on him
and sticking up for me. And then on top of this, how are you?
You literally just made a video
on him and sticking up for me. And then on top of this,
uh, your mic might be a little low. Let me see if I I view at
200%. You might have to get closer to it.
>> Okay. Check. Check. One, two.
>> It's way better. Thank you very much. >> How are
you? You literally just made a video before this talking about
society doesn't accept change. Oh my god. We We got to be so
hung up on the past and past things that were said and tweeted.
You're doing the same thing. This whole video This whole video
is you doing that, girl. What are you on about? I think my mic
is peeking. If it is, my bad. I just so stupid. So dumb. And
by this point, Brad isn't a bad guy. All right. Uh, he's just
an idiot that can't take criticism for and he lets his audience
dictate him. >> Yes, Chad. I'm so sorry. I will give you
head because I didn't mute the mic before ripping abs. Like,
yeah, he says some dumb [__] but he's open about
the dumb [__] he said and is showing. >> Chud
got caught in Rose's DMs. In what context, Black, >> stop
it. >> In what context? >> That is Yeah, >> that
is slander. That's defamation.
I assume you just mean messaging this person cuz they did content
like asked them to come on stream or something. That's probably
the context you mean >> that he learned and was changing
while Rose Malay is here displaying. Uh >> that's not the
context you meant.
No. Yeah, I I'm going to need evidence of that before I believe
it. I need a screenshot. I would need some evidence of that.
I don't believe it. I don't believe it. I don't believe it. >> I
actually don't want that evidence. I want you to keep that one
to yourself. Take that to the grave.
how of a person she is in real time. Now, again, uh I'm going
to keep everything surface level. I'm going to end the Rose Malay
saga here, but this whole rabbit hole, go look it up. Now, what
tends to happen uh when somebody is getting dunked is uh more
>> Man, I actually did cover some of these now that I think
about it. Yeah. How he like didn't pay what do you call it? Didn't
pay the person for some work. >> People come out of the
woodworks with information that uh they can use to just air out
the dirty laundry, strike by the iron tide. this guy's getting
dunked on. Let me let me share my information I have with the
guy that I've had for a while because of course this is the most
appropriate time. Um which by the way to be fair um I'm I'm unsure
of when this next story happened. Maybe it happened during the
Rose Malay H3 thing. I have no idea. But what we do know is this
story came out right after the the H3 call-in. I think now an
editor that worked with Brad claimed that Brad left her bank
account in the negatives. Uh because Brad Brad paid this editor
then refunded the bread. It's a mess because I saw there was
also something about it being like a PayPal issue after the editor
told Brad about this. He only sent half of the money so the account
was still in the negatives and only paid the rest of the debt
when the editor went public about this on Twitter. Now my question
is why the can he just pay the editor out? He got the funds because
as I said earlier he charges $9 per minute for a song. If you
do the math on that it's pretty often when the queue is closed.
By the way, brother's making $540 an hour. That is more than
a brain surgeon. So the >> that's not what he's making.
He definitely doesn't get paid every hour for music. Like he
doesn't have like a full queue the whole time. There's no >> Whole
thing is weird. >> And what makes weirder is uh him ebgging
his chat for 10 grand again almost immediately after this whole
editor thing went down. And admittedly I'm not too familiar with
this story because again that's an entire thing. Uh
>> what's why why people got to hate on ebgging? That's
like the whole streaming thing. You make content creation. You
make content you're ebggging in one way or another. You're like
e begging for people to watch and support you. It's all ebegging.
Don't Don't denigrate ebegging, guys. Come on. >> The editor
ended up leaving the internet or something because of how stress
she was. During this whole thing, Brad actually called her up
and is saying like, "Oh, I just got out of jail because of this
DV case and and it's nutty." And I promise the DV thing, it's
going to wrap everything around. But hopefully at some point
in time, someone drops an entire documentary covering every story
and every nook and every cranny. But uh I'm not doing that because
this video is already taking a little too long. So, let's just
move on. Now, after all this [__] went down in such
a short period of time, he basically went from being wellresected
to being a local in a matter of weeks. And uh just gets worse
and worse for the man because he just doesn't know how to maneuver
in the online space and he just doesn't know what he should and
shouldn't ignore. Now, between a peak of the Brad Tay controversy
and a few weeks ago when things started to respspark, uh I'm
not entirely sure what went down. I know at some point he claimed
to go on a hiatus but returned one week later. Uh, I know people
claim that he was lying about going to rehab for his weed
>> That's the one I know about. >> Is that a real
thing? >> Yeah. Well, it's a real thing he said he was
doing. That he needed to go to rehab for his weed addiction.
Yes. No. >> Maybe he also talked about getting
>> Well, something neurotic people do. Maybe. I think he
he talked about how he hallucinated really heavily while smoking
weed too, didn't he? >> Didn't he talk about like basically
>> It's possible. I think >> I think it is possible.
It's a really rare complication, though. >> Very rare.
I think it was um one of the first people I heard talking about
that was Britney Simon says she got her ego death with like marijuana.
Usually it ticks like um what is it >> Oh
um >> psychedelics, right? >> Yeah. Yeah. Usually
psychedelics. Col says he's bipolar. Apparently gets weed psychosis.
Apparently it's a
>> I didn't even know that. >> So damn. >> And
then yeah it is addictive by the way. All right. If you're one
of those people that say weed isn't addicting. I think uh that
says more about you than it does me, but he cut back a little
bit. And I know a lot of fans were concerned at some point because
he was just on that deep end and just like very visibly unstable.
His partner Tina crashed out on stream just yelling like, "You
guys want him to be a local, but it's not going to work. We're
not going to be low cows." And then it happens. But let's just
f
That's not good. You guys want me to be a local cow, but I won't
do it. I won't do it. is not a good look ever. Okay,
don't don't do that. >> Fast forward to what happened 2
weeks ago. Uh because at some point he did end up taking a long
break from the internet until he dropped this video that is now
deleted and it's titled Si. Now, at this point, things became
a little bit more dark, a little bit more scary. So, this SI
video, he basically tells the entire
>> Hold on. Hold on. That's not one of the ones we have,
is it? That's not this one. No, that's a different one. Okay.
Okay. We're watching. We're watching >> story that I just
covered, but from his perspective. Uh he admits that he shouldn't
have let Twitter control him. He goes on about his recent life
updates and his newfound connection with his father. However,
uh the issue with this video is he brings up things that didn't
need to be said. He brings up things that completely
Okay, hold on. Can we watch this video? Si Brad tasting music
>> What's up? So I I I want to try to >> this a 28
minute video on I guess his what his weed addiction mostly and
then Twitter baiting him into getting into more drama. you guys
what's going on through my head because it's it's pretty
>> Um, I had to just go to my computer and hit record
uh because I know I have to make this video and not for the reason
that you think I have to make this video like I'm saving my reputation.
Um, but
>> cuz I'm burning it. >> If I don't make this video,
I'm going to keep thinking about it.
Like for some reason like 11 months ago when like everything
went down with my channel um I've just been like contemplating
the perfect video, you know, that'll fix it all. I'll just say
the the right words and everything will go back to normal. Um
I have learned since then that that is not reality and I don't
want it to be reality. So uh basically I'm here making this video
really for the reason that like I want to get certain information
across to people who care. Um and I don't really know a better
way to do >> Evil Excel, thank you for the 11 months. Appreciate
it, buddy. Thank you. Thank
>> Realistically, like yes, I would love for this video
to like uh yeah, make it so that like it's easy for me to just
return, you know, go back to normal what I was doing before,
you know? But the reality is is I could do that anyways. Um I'm
in a good spot right now where artistically I'm confident enough
in myself to where if I started making content, I believe that
people would enjoy it enough um to basically just assume on their
own that I'm doing good. Um I really don't need a video telling
them I'm doing good, you know, for them to understand it. >> Yes.
like I could just go the uh sneaky underground, you know, mysterious
artist route that like honestly I've seen everybody do. Everybody's
doing it. Um but I decided
no. So, uh despite how much I really am struggling, let's talk.
>> dude. No, no, no, no. This is I He should not He should
not do that. Start from the beginning. This does not seem like
a guy who should be, you know,
if your problem is that you're sensitive to Twitter comments,
this is not of like where things went wrong. >> I don't
think >> I went to a show. It was a live show in California.
It was Ethan Klein and Ela Klein performing. I had backstage
passes. I met them. I talked with them. I related a lot to them,
especially uh with her struggles with being right now. And like
how like it's how do I say this? It's like >> he is hold
right now. But he is he had family killed in October 7th. Yeah.
So that it was right after October 7th too. This is like right
after
year after >> Well, it is hard being it's tough to be.
It ain't easy. >> Like even now like I don't want to [__]
talk about it. Like I really don't, you know, but what I want
you to understand is that like my horrible response to this whole
situation is uh a long-term thing or or like uh is the result
of a lot of stuff, you know? It's like the moment where things
snap. It's not the moment where it's like everything went wrong
basically.
Um, so like at this time, you know, um, like I post a picture
that I have with me, uh, some friends, my fiance Ethan and Ela
Klein. And basically, uh, I was like, "Yeah, yeah, I could post
that. It's great." You know, I didn't think it would be a statement.
It was really stupid of me because of course it's a statement.
It's Ethan and Ela Klein. Um, but I wasn't really ready for war.
I wanted to back out. So like, I basically just went against
them and said, "You know what? I need I need to back out. I can't
do this. You know, this this is too too hot." And then everyone
called me, which I mean to be fair like I kind of was, but also
at the same time I I thought that my choice was understandable.
Like I had a family to take care of, you know, like I didn't
want this to become my life. Uh the problem is it wasn't that
easy to get out. Uh so yeah, you know, people are talking about
it. I'm I'm a hot topic. Um and my partner is freaking out because
she's involved. You know, she's a part of the whole equation.
>> I also Yeah, I don't know why that happened. She had
like nothing to do with his content at all. And then she started
like getting on stream with him, which I feel like is probably
never a good sign for a content creator. Like if you don't have
any relationship with the content and then suddenly you start
getting on stream, that's like odd >> in my opinion. >> And
I start trying to, you know, say things to fix it. And when I
try to help, it basically results in her screaming and crying
that things are getting worse and that it's all my
>> A New York thing for the seven months. Let's go. Let's
go. Thank you. Thank you. >> So, I'm trying to, you know,
keep my job cuz I'm paying her ridiculous amount of money. Like
$5,000 a month to basically do nothing. And I'm going to be honest
with you guys. I don't I don't have a problem with that. You
know, keep my job >> cuz I'm paying her ridiculous amount
of money. Like $5,000 a month uh to basically do nothing. And
I'm going to be honest with you guys. I don't I don't have a
problem with that. Like if like paying her five grand a month
so she could, you know, lay around, smoke weed on the couch and
be happy, great, you know? But um >> I don't think that
she really respected me. I don't think >> I that doesn't
sound great. I don't know. Yeah, it doesn't sound the best. >> She
saw things in me that were like important for her to see. So,
um it went really bad. >> Like as soon as that the picture
was posted, it like it became me panicking trying to fix it and
her basically getting angry at me trying to fix it. Um, I'd say
that everything reached an apex
when she she recorded me in my house yelling at her through the
door. I was [__] I was just like mad cuz I'm trying
to I'm trying to figure everything out in like an imp. >> Now,
spoiler alert, that's going to become very relevant in about
30 minutes. All right. That she recorded >> He knew about
this recording and he went on to talk.
>> Yes. Which is the thing that makes this crazy. And he
like Yeah.
Apparently this recording is like nuts and he knew about it and
he still like and she basically was going to post it was going
to like blow him up and then he was like oh actually I'm going
to take some time off guys I'm I'm really not in a good place
and she like didn't post it and then he came back some some amount
of time later was like actually this was crazy and then she posted
it possible situation you know trying to get things back to normal
so that like we can live a normal life and um she repays me by
recording in my house without my knowledge. She sends it to my
parents. She sends it to friends. She sends it to people who
are associated with hide mind. Yeah. And uh it's it's the biggest
betrayal I've ever felt. I really like I felt so violated.
But like she couldn't hear that because she looked up that it
was legal to do that, you know, to like record me in that state.
And because it was legal, it was moral to do that, you know.
But like, man,
you I like at that point I was done with her. Like at that point,
I was like, "This is
like I'm doing everything I can in this situation to make things
work. I love you, but we're not going to be a good match." So,
yeah. I believe maybe like a week later I was streaming. Um,
when I said I remember I >> I feel like I feel like people
took stills like out of this video and like there there are just
a lot of really good stills from this video. Yeah, I believe
maybe like a week >> like this right here
like that. That's a great still out of this video. Very low resolution
unfortunately.
>> Um
when I said I remember I I was like doing a stream and then I
left. I go to the kitchen. I see her sitting on the couch like
screaming and crying and I'm off like
because like I'm trying to focus, you know, to get work done
and it felt like she was interrupting that. Now, here's the thing.
What I want you to understand out of all of this, and remember
how I said that it was all like, you know, it wasn't just this
scenario happening, that this was like a long-term effect.
Well, um, I was so obsessed with my work, I became like completely
locked into that to the point where she has told me that she
felt completely invisible in the relationship. Um, yeah, my response
just reacting to music.
>> Yeah, just listens to music and like kind of cries about
it.
Why is this what streamers do? Why do streamers act like they
are they're actually like
>> put the emotional music reacts in the bag, little bro?
Just put them in the bag.
Give me the Give me the entertainment. This is a transaction.
Yeah. I don't know. I also don't know why he's talking about
their relationship dynamic at this point either. It's just context
you don't need in my opinion. >> Her crying was >> screaming
at her which was bad. But my justification was I am streaming
right now. I can't have you like screaming and crying like in
the house. You know, I told her to go basically stay with her
mother who lived like 5 minutes away. Uh instead of doing that,
she >> That's tough. >> Got me kicked. Okay. So,
I'm um I'm like >> some recording. Is that Fant?
>> This thing where I'm like, "You need to go to your mom's
house." And she's like, you know, "Fuck you. This is my house,
too." And I'm like, "I pay all the bills. This is all important.
This is all important. Trust me." >> Is it? I pay the bills
for this entire place, you know, like I'm keeping it up. You
don't contribute to the equation. Get out. Um, she calls the
cops on me and they have me arrested for domestic violence.
That is really where the story all starts. Like, you know, I'm
in a jail cell.
This was like literally there's like a clip of me that's like
me talking about how I don't feel safe in >> uh pause.
That's me. And I guess you're probably wondering just how I got
here into this jail cell. Like, yeah, that's where this all starts,
guys. >> And like an hour later, I'm in jail. You know,
it's crazy. And I don't want to [__] say any of this.
I don't want to talk about this. It makes me look bad. But I'm
also now realizing that I don't really care because that's what
happened. Those are, you know, that's what I did. These are the
choices I made. Um, anyways. Yeah. So, once that happens, the
relationship is over. I'm just like, yeah. So, you know, I move
back home and I go to rehab because like something's wrong, you
know, like all of this is happening and just I don't understand
it.
>> Rehab is okay, you know? I learned a few
>> you know, like in 5 months of being there. Like, yeah,
you know, there was stuff that was helpful. >> Five months.
>> 5 months. How bad was his addiction? Doesn't it take
like 3 weeks to
>> kick a habit? >> That can't possibly be true.
5 months in rehab would be so expensive. Yeah. I don't I don't
know. But man, I felt so betrayed. She basically
took
like she moved to Detroit and here's kind of where it gets difficult
for me because it's one thing like losing your partner. It's
another thing like with losing hive mind like the fact that like
these two things were so connected. >> Uh we got a we got
a lore master here who knows
anything. I'm not in a game
>> but yeah. What is what is hide mine? We got any lore
masters here can tell us about the Brad Tay stuff >> that
like his um audience having the same perception of him. >> Well,
yeah. I don't know if it's if he's losing high. Yeah, if it's
like um >> Yeah, maybe that's what it means. Hide mind
is a YouTube channel of friends. Oh, okay. >> Oh, okay.
>> Okay, cool. It's some YouTube channel who's collabing
with. I got it. It's like a group of friends. I got it. Cool,
cool, cool, cool, cool. >> I almost killed myself over
it. Like, >> don't show us how much. Don't show us how
close you were.
>> Uh-huh.
Okay. I
>> hidden vodka. He's pulled out the hidden vodka. Nothing
good coming now. >> And I had pills. However, good news
is this happened 3 months ago and there's this much alcohol in
the bottle. That means something went well. It means something's
something's going right. >> I think it means you failed,
but that's >> Let's talk about Hivemind.
Hivemind is a collective of guys who I very much respect. Um,
but Riley is a diva and Graden's a brute. Here's the thing though,
that just makes me like them more because they're very human.
In fact, I think that like their flaws are the things that really,
you know, attracted me to them, you know, what really made me
like interested in them as people, you know, what made me connect
with them on like a much deeper level. So, you know, the fact
that like my ex moves to Detroit,
like around all these like hive mind people and then starts like
dating Graden's roommate,
you know, and like Riley leaves me on
>> That's
rough that your ex moved to where your like content creation
friends are and then started dating somebody in their circle.
>> That's
weird. That's just weird. Detroit's a big place. I think >> Graden's
roommate,
you know, and like Riley leaves me on Red
and it's just like wow.
>> I really love the people at Hivemind still. Like in
case you don't know who Hivemind is, I collaborated with them.
They're like a pretty big channel, but just they did to me what
they did to Nick is not green. I remember when I was there and
they were telling me the story. Nick is not green. Great friends,
you know, he has uh his thing that >> Nick is not green
sucks, by the way. And bye-bye. >> I don't think that really
needs to be said. That guy's the worst. >> He's the He's
like the black lefty guy who black soy lefty guy. Is he black?
He might be like Iranian or something. I don't He's got like
the the curly. >> You just remember that he sucks, so he
must be black. >> Wait, I hope I didn't just Who this is?
It's the glasses kid, right? Yeah. Okay. Holy [__]
>> Hi. Happy Monday. >> Is this guy Did this guy
come back? Is he like back? No. Three years ago. Nick is not
green. That was like the second Isn't he back one year? >> I
thought that guy's back. >> He like did an apology video,
but I think he [__] off. He might have a second channel.
There's like >> I swear I saw that guy back this year.
>> Green is not Nick is his other channel 7 days ago. 30,000
views. No, he still he gets pretty reasonable. Yeah, two weeks
10 months ago. >> Everyone forgave him. Didn't he come
back and was like, "Yeah, up." >> I think he came back
and basically said like, "Yeah, my bad." Or something.
I think you did like eight apology vids. Okay.
Well, I make harmful content. That needs to change.
Yeah.
Guy just kind of sucked in a lot of ways. It was what it was.
Anyway, >> Nick is >> I was trying to think of like
how I could I was going to say he looks like but no, never mind.
>> No longer associated with the name. Now, of course,
at the time, I'm just thinking like, oh, thank god I'm on the
>> It's got such a distinctive look. I thought I could
um I thought I could nail it. And then I froze, you know, of
of but then I ended up on the other side of things >> and
I actually well I would say became friends with Nick is not green
but I honestly just I don't I think he sent me a message like
5 months ago that I never checked. So even then like I'm not
doing great with that but like I got to see that perspective
you know I got to see both sides and in my opinion I don't give
a [__] Whatever.
Moving on. Let's talk about where things start getting good.
Look at this picture right here. Okay. Now, I'm going to explain
this picture later, but this is a bee being, you know, that's
dead. It's being carried by an ant. All right.
Sorry. Uh, wherever this story goes is going to be good. Uh,
she put me in jail for domestic violence. Also, look at this
bee being carried by this ant. Here's where the story gets good.
>> I saw this with my own two eyes in nature. A bee being
carried by an ant down a line. All right. That was that, you
know, that's some life-changing stuff. It's weird. It's like
it's really symbolic to me. But, uh, you know, maybe it's like,
uh, maybe I feel like it's a symbol of me somehow uh, overcoming,
you know, a lot of stuff that's been going on. Uh, it starts
with 4 months ago when I decided to stop streaming and stop working.
Uh, it basically came down to I can't do this anymore. I um,
I can't do it anymore. Like, something is wrong, you know? So,
um,
so I'm like I don't really know what is wrong. I just feel like
I shouldn't stream. So, instead I start watching movies and I
kind of come to the idea that like I don't really know if I should
work cuz I really don't want to, you know, I just >> No,
I don't.
A lot of people would love to know what that feels like. I just
kind of keep sitting around all day watching movies
and then it's like the stuff with my ex and like with Hivemind
and how that's all connected, you know? I just I can't get it
out of my head. I can't. It's like no matter what I do, that's
like like my ex leaving
to go and like be a part of Highmind and Graden's roommate, you
know, like Yeah. Well, I wasn't taking it so well. So, uh, just
thinking every day how I was going to kill myself and then eventually
came up with drinking and pills. Um,
then my cousin came and visited and everything changed. This
was the moment where it all turned around. I'm driving with him.
I live in Arizona and so I'm driving with him in the car and
he is ooing and aawing at the world around him and I'm like,
"What are you even talking about? This is like this brown dead
like spot. Like, how are you finding anything of beauty here?"
You know? And then we go upstate and he um he's talking to my
dad and he's like connecting with my dad in a way that I've never
connected to my dad and he's like very peppy and optimistic.
And then I'm having dinner with him and my mom. Oh yeah, that's
the other thing. I had to move back in with my parents. That
was another big reason I wanted to give myself. I was
>> I thought he makes so much money.
>> Uh he did make a lot of money but he was what 7 months
5 months in rehab 7 months off working. I actually that's not
relatable to me. I could totally move in with my parents. It
would just feel like a step backwards in life. I actually get
along with my parents just like perfectly fine. I know that's
like not I don't I don't want to say like yeah, preach it. I
get a lot but it would just feel weird going back to your parents
house after being out for like a decade. >> It's like I
went from like big shot to you know back to the place where I
thought I was running from where I thought that it was like this
is where all the problems were. >> My cousin invites me
to go to Switzerland and Egypt with >> what? Oh, >> I
was like in that moment it's like oh he was like running away
from like his parents. Maybe his home life was like really problematic.
>> Oh yeah, that's a good point. I missed that he was connecting
those. Yeah,
that I but then he's lamenting not connecting to his dad. So
that seems weird to me >> I was like I went from like big
shot to, you know, back to the place where I thought I was running
from where I thought that it was like this is where all the problems
were. My cousin invites me to go to Switzerland and Egypt with
him. And reluctantly
but quickly, I answer yes because I know how important this is
if this is like going to do what I think it is. And I mean, I
dude, uh, I want this cous cousin to come on stream. This guy's
cousin just rolls in and like is super happy and gets him like
out of his depression to go on a vacation. Can we get the cousin
to be on stream, Brad? Can we meet your cousin? He sounds awesome.
I've already wanted to die. So, like like what is there to lose
at this point, right? So, uh the time comes, I leave the country.
It's amazing. Switzerland is absolutely gorgeous. Um being around
people who don't speak the same language as as you was really
nice cuz like I didn't feel anxious as if like everybody was
watching me, you know? Um >> that's crazy, Chad. >> Just
like I always feel like I have to connect with people, you know,
and when they're not speaking English, like there's no chance
for me to connect with them cuz I was lonely. I had no friends
out here. I didn't know how to talk to people. Like I literally
felt like I couldn't get out of this, you know? And for a moment,
I didn't have to. I could just be in it. I could just indulge
in it. And it's that mindset that really got me
a like really far through this whole process. Um, yeah. I mean,
I I I had fun with Switzerland. There's not really much to say.
I took a picture that's one of the best things I've ever seen
in my life. I'm waiting to write a song for it, you know, because
I need to crop the image and add an explicit symbol on it, you
know, cuz then it becomes the real deal. You'll see one day.
I come back. I'm feeling okay. I'm feeling all right. But I have
a plan B in case that happens. And that's that I had a second
vacation planned. The second uh trip was to Minnesota.
>> Okay. For I was like, for the love of God, don't say
Detroit. Don't say Detroit. Don't say Detroit. Don't say >> to
basically sleep in a music studio with a bunch of people. >> Isn't
Isn't that close to Detroit? >> Yeah. It's like one state
over. It's like Minnesota, Wisconsin, Detroit.
Minnesota, Wisconsin, uh Michigan.
>> Uh that Dylan basically, you know, he's friends with.
and we're all going to stay in this music studio while Dylan
records music. Um, and you know, with doing this, I connected
with people and I found like a family through it and I realized,
oh, there are people like me. I can connect to people. This is
like, you know, not only that, but I can connect to people who
are interested in the same thing as me and it doesn't need to
be online. Um, being in the studio showed me that like there's
all this cool stuff with music and I don't need to just like,
you know, be stuck behind um, a desk doing YouTube for forever.
I come back and I'm like, okay, you know, that was like the greatest
experience of my life. Like, that was life-changing.
And now all of a sudden I'm doing pretty good, but I still don't
want to work. And it's weird. I don't really fully understand
why because like I'm feeling better, right? Why don't I want
to go in front of a camera and have everybody, you know, listen
to me talk about stuff and judge me for it, you know? >> Uh
because that's like the source of your previous like mental decline,
I assume. Isn't that one pretty easy? Why don't I want to go
back to the thing that actually made me like massively mentally
decline in my life? Why is he asking that question? That's That's
just pretty obvious, isn't it? >> It just sounds like anxiety.
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> Um, turns out that it's not because
I don't like that. Uh, but it's because I've actually burnt myself
out so badly with music that I [__] hate it. And
not only that, but Brad Taste in music, like thinking the name,
saying it out loud, gave me like this, even now gives me this
sinking pit in my stomach feeling, like this just absolutely
awful feeling. Um, like I don't feel happy thinking about working
on my YouTube channel anymore, you know, in the same way that
I used to. At least I didn't. I'll say that like right. >> Sorry.
Somebody just asked uh is he getting wetter over time. I think
he is like this isn't like him showering and getting on camera.
It is him like sweating bullets for whatever reason while he
does this cuz yeah, I don't think it's He's like not drying out
at >> Now it's better. But like, you know, 2 months ago
it was pretty much like uh I'm I'm enjoying everything else that
has to do with music right now that isn't like my job. I'm starting
to like care about it again. And that's cuz of one thing. Uh
my friend Kendall, I I would visit him. We would go and watch
a movie and then we would sit at the park sometimes in my car.
We would smoke weed and we would listen to music and watching
him react to the [__] that I was playing and hearing
how it was making me feel and seeing his reaction and just like
it was
it was amazing. It was just what I needed. So after that, I started,
you know, I wasn't even thinking about music after that moment
or I'm sorry, YouTube after that moment. It just became how do
I entertain this guy? So, I just start driving and listening
to music, thinking like, "Okay, will this song like go hard?"
You know, being high in a car with him, you >> Uh, give
me I'm going to be right back in like 45 seconds. Give me a second.
>> Give me two Well, give me 45 seconds. >> And I
ended up just like saving a bunch of songs that I felt would
work in that environment specifically for that environment. And
then, um, yeah, then I share them with him. U, but he's not always
available. And every single day I'm out like for hours just driving
with no destination, just listening to music. I need other people
to hang out with. So, I have other friends who once again I can
just like sit in the car with and listen to music and chill out
and show them things and all of a sudden I'm starting to find,
you know, that interest in all this stuff that I cared about
before and I'm starting to remember why it is that I like it.
You know, it's on a good path. And then I do something that,
okay, let's just say a week ago, it's the reason I'm making this
video cuz I finally feel like I'm actually ready to make this.
A week ago was where like it all came together. Remember how
I said I never really had that real connection with my dad? Well,
I wondered if it was because like he never had someone in his
life just like unconditionally listen and want to be around him
and just give him attention, you know, just pay attention to
him. >> I did that and it was magic. It was incredible.
I I now have a a real relationship with my dad >> and a
lot of that was built on like um like we would wake up >> needing
to >> and we would go >> just listen there and fanboy
for him. What does this mean?
>> I don't. My dad never had anybody who just wanted to
sit there, listen, and care about what he had to say. And I finally
did that for him. >> Our relationship's really good now.
>> When we drive up a mountain, and we there was this exact
bench. We would, you know, in the trunk of my car, we had like
uh tribal drums and a gong, you know, different sticks to hit
things with. And I was making music in nature with my dad, you
know, and just like connecting and like improvising. And it >> these
guys were doing African spirituals out in the jungle together,
these two white men. >> Great. Like it was good [__]
Like >> sorry. African spirituals and like Chinese music.
The gong.
I don't I don't even know what it would sound like. I don't know
why I think gongs sound like gong either. I don't think the sound
you make when you hit a gong is gong, but in my head that made
sense.
I just going to hit play. >> I think that's accurate. >> Is
it? Is it all right?
Yeah, I think I'm I'm cooking here. you know, through this time
with my dad that he is
I'm just going to say it like a musical genius, which I'm like
perfectly comfortable saying because I' I've heard how he puts
sounds together and it's like nothing I've ever heard. It's immaculate.
Like to like it's at the highest degree, you know, which is amazing
because I thought my dad was just an addict when he said that
my music wasn't good, you know, or the stuff that I liked he
wasn't like connecting with. But then like I actually finally
heard and saw what he saw and it all made sense. I was like,
you really are looking for frequency." Like, you're looking for
nesting. You're looking for environment, atmosphere, like more
than anything. And amazingly, that's what I look for the most
out of anything. So, we just artistically clicked. And yeah,
so he's going back to work.
Looks like I'm supposed to be going back to work, but I'm going
to be honest, I might not even go to work. I don't even think
I care enough to be honest. Um, honestly, this part of the video
seems totally fine. I don't know why he threw his relationship
details in. if he just wanted to talk about how he was depressed
and like he went and like hung out with his dad and reconnected
with him. There's like nothing embarrassing there. That's like
all solid stories like maybe a little bit like who asked, but
that's all fine. The stuff with the domestic abuse, I don't know
why you include any of that in your video. >> Yeah, especially
if I if I post this video. I'm definitely I don't know what the
hell I'm doing. All right, let's think. What have I not mentioned
yet? Um
there are many members of the community who've given a lot to
this channel who have received absolutely nothing in return.
not even like acknowledgement from me, you know, in a way that's
cold. In a way that they recognize that they feel and they feel
betrayed with. I've lost two Discords. Okay, I've lost two, not
one, two Discords to mutiny.
All right, so clearly I'm not doing something right. Um, I'm
aware of that. However, I I've cleverly installed BB Poison as
the number two person in my Discord. Okay, BB Poison is actually
just me. All right,
we built we built I built this whole career myself. Okay, BB
Poison. I gave the computer myself. I gifted all these subs to
myself. It's actually just me and you all think it's second person.
Okay, you'll never mutiny me cuz the person you need to turn
for the mutiny is me.
>> Uh, all I can do is try my best moving forward and Oh,
yeah. Stream FKA Twigs. There you go. All right, that's it. Bye.
>> Oh, what? What? That's such a weird way for that to
end. Also, could I have just clicked this and we've been on a
high-res version of the video where we could really see how sweaty
he was? Damn it. I watched the low res version. So, this is back
this was back in July.
That's not That's not this video. Okay, so that came out. Whatever.
He was maybe going to go back to work. Hold on. We'll go back
to the timeline video. We'll let this guy carry us through the
timeline a little bit more and then we'll see. So, this is the
SI. >> Makes him look insane because he went in depth on
his relationship with his ex- fiance Tina. And to be honest,
he again, he didn't have to tell us anything about it. Nobody
gave a [__] about their relationship really. Like,
they weren't like an internet couple. Oh, look at the internet
power couple. They're going to make great content together. Like,
no, dog. She's just like someone in his personal life, and it
should have stood that way. But anyway, he essentially called
her a paid couch potato. Uh, told us how tight she was when he
was getting exposed and pressuring him to do damage control.
But the interesting bits is when he said that his wife recorded
him yelling at her or fiance. So, he self admits that he has
a yelling problem like in a few videos and his ex- fiance has
trouble with that, which Brad was well aware of. Again, I'm going
to show you guys that in a bit. Uh, then he goes on to say, "Yeah,
I felt betrayed and violated because my fianceé recorded me yelling
at her and sent it to our friends and family." You know what,
Tina? You up. Okay, Tina, how dare you uh violate this? >> That's
not good. Okay, you're violated because somebody recorded you
being like abusive. Oh, yeah. I've got a bit of a yelling problem.
I feel like I feel like you can't really be mad when when that
person's like trying to show you how bad the problem is. It's
like a little different, right? >> Man, that's violating
you. How dare you not be verbally abused in private? Tina, that
damn Tina, you're so right, Brad. She should have kept this [__]
behind. Close door. You're on to something. Uh, but then he goes
on to say that the recording is the last straw and they broke
up after that. Now, I have the recording here, which I will show
you guys in full. It It's just leaked audio and warning, it is
very uncomfortable to listen to. So, uh, again, warning, you
could skip ahead 2 minutes or a minute and 22 seconds if you
don't want to hear it. But here it is. >> One second. [__]
I was going to try to find a clip of me speaking for a while,
but I'm not going to be able to so I can damn right I do that
to you. I can kick you the out of here for what the [__]
you've done to me. You destroy me. >> What? How? All I
ever want to do is >> Stop lying to me for once. Look at
me in the eyes and stop lying to me. Stop being such a wimp.
>> All I've ever >> Look at me and accept what you
have done to me. Do you see what I've become? You me you
I'm sorry. Do you see what I've become? goes so hard. Do you
see what I've
>> That's awesome. You >> promised me everything.
You lied to me. Look at me. The I can say that again. Look at
me. Tell me. Tell me. Tell me what the you just said. Tell me.
Get out of my house. >> Get out of my house. >> What's
wrong with you? Don't do it. Don't do it. Don't. Don't. You're
evil. But you're evil.
Uh yeah. Uh very disturbing. Very very sad to listen to. >> Jesus
Christ. This part sucks though. He's sobbing. Wait, weren't they
both?
You are evil. But you're evil.
>> Uh yeah. Uh very disturbing. Very very sad to listen
to. Now Tina does mention that he's ever been violent towards
her, but uh I'm not going to lie. Uh this sounds like a violent
fella to me. While I do believe her, I just feel like this audio
sounds like someone that's not right in the head. And people
do [__] when they're not right in the head. So, I
definitely would be care. >> Yeah, but I I mean, doesn't
he like literally admit he's not right in the head? Doesn't that
video sound like like that was that might have been less bad
than I was expecting given the out the what do you call it? Like
the um a public outcry. Why not just play the full recording?
That was I think the video the recording is like a minute and
20 seconds. That's not to say none of that's bad. It just sounds
basically exactly like what I assumed it would sound like. Right.
So you cut out the last 20 seconds where Tina just breaks down
and so Oh, excuse me. Jesus. Well, that's pretty rough. There's
a second part. Hold on. >> What am I so I can damn right
do that to you? I can kick you the out of here for what the [__]
Don't do it. Don't do it. Don't that my don't you are evil
but you're evil.
>> That's pretty upsetting
uh to hear.
>> It's It's rough to listen to for sure. Like I think
clearly the guy's got problems, right? He's got major problems,
but I kind of already knew he had major problems. So it's like
not to say it's okay. It's definitely not okay, but like Yeah.
I don't know. He sounds like somebody who's got like major mental
health issues who's like having a
>> And didn't she didn't she not post this until he like
returned and made content
>> her or something? >> So, I feel like he returned
and this guy seems to have skipped it. I don't know why, but
there's a he seems to have skipped the comeback video, which
was Hold on. Run this audio.
I I believe it's this one right here.
>> my statement re-upload. I believe this is his his video
when he came back and basically makes a statement on her. >> Let
me start this. >> So this this would have preceded that
audio being leaked. So she had that audio. Brad referenced it
in July or even before that, I think, right? And then he said,
"Actually, I'm going to take some time away. I'm like not going
to do anything."
And I think he was gone for a while. And then he like brought
it up. I don't know why he brought it up. this uh very dramatic
speech by saying that the last uh week or two I I haven't even
been keeping track the last week or two really hurt a lot. It's
really sucked. But I've also gained a lot of information. I've
seen how people interact, how people interact with me, you know,
who sticks around, who leaves, why that is. And I think that
like a lot of it makes more sense to me. But today, okay, I'm
going to be bringing up Yes, I am talking about this. I'm going
to be bringing up my exartner,
but I want it. I want to make it very clear
um that everything I am about to say, I have zero intention of
saying like or or or like trying to victimize myself through
what she
>> well has done. I'm going to be accusing her of some
pretty hefty things, but I want to show you that I have a pretty
strong understanding of the situation. And I truly do believe
that like we are both victims in this situation, like equally.
And in the leadup to the in the leadup recording, both threatened
to call the police on each other for emotional abuse. That could
be like a bad recording of one side of that where it actually
goes that hard in both directions. That's possible, right? You
don't know that for sure. And he is like accusing her of some
stuff. Man, I don't know what you do in that situation. If you
feel like it was mutual, I think you maybe still walk away, but
I don't know. Other people would argue that if you just let What
are you like never going to be able to talk about this person
ever again because they have this thing on you? I don't know.
Oh, there's a Rose Malay response to this. Yoink. blowing. >> I've
even talked with her about this before, you know, like victims
of the age of the internet in a way, but I I think that it's
different than that. Um I think that there is just something
fun like fundamentally broken between me and her. Um no, I did
not abuse my partner. I have never even had a thought of harming
her like once in my life. I've never put a finger near her. But
also at the same time, >> um, everything she's saying,
you know, about being extremely hurt and horrified and, you know,
like, uh, >> oh, there's a full 10-minute recording apparently.
I didn't know that. That there was a full 10-minute recording.
Complete Brad Taste abuse audio. Oh, well, we'll finish this
video first. We'll finish this video. Nope, this video first.
This is the the one from about a week ago. not wanting to be
around me and you know how she she truly believes that everything
she's done is in self-defense. And what I'm here to say is I
completely believe her, but I also think it's worth mentioning
the things that she did in self-defense and like why they would
result in me losing it and screaming, you know. Um well, first
of all, let's talk about the main issue, me yelling. like when
I get very angry or even excited or just anything like I get
very loud like it I use my voice and the volume of it to really
express it. So like when I'm upset because of something, you
know, and I start getting really loud about it. Um
like that basically was her biggest fear
cuz she had trauma uh with yelling.
Make sure I get all >> that's a I don't know why you make
this video without a script too. off the cuff is pretty crazy
to just like have this pause and then like >> I'm sorry
just that point like she has trauma with yelling like nobody
likes >> as opposed to all the people who love being yelled
at like screamed at directly in their face. Yeah. >> Yeah.
It's a good point. >> Pretty sure any person would have
a problem with him doing that
>> details, right? This kind of complicated. So basically
for me though, like my family, everyone I've been around my whole
life is loud. They talk over each other. They yell at each other,
but they never mean anything bad by it. So, I never really saw
anything wrong with it. They're just trying to be heard and get
their point across and, you know, show their emotions. And so,
that's like me when I'm yelling. And
>> So, the problem is is Tina, I guess I'm just saying
her name. Sure. Tina. Um,
Tina rightfully like
gets scared of that, is horrified. What I'm trying to say by
this is this situation is a matter of a bad match because we
like worked perfectly with everything, but it really was me yelling.
And again, I would basically yell because, you know, just like
out of instinct of trying to get a point across or even sometimes
just tell a joke. And the way that she would handle it is she
>> he yells to deliver his jokes. That's uh >> would
feel hurt and scared. >> And this just kept happening over
and over again where I didn't mean to scare her. Yeah, she got
scared. She like she starts acting very nervous and then I'm
like questioning why she is and then
um that's when like I would start yelling and then I'd see how
upset she was. like, "Holy [__] wait, no, this is
not what what was supposed to like I was just trying to, you
know, get my point across." And that would basically be like
a very scary memory, you know, being built. And that would happen
over and over and over again to the point of where she started
to fear me. And this is what I mean when I say that like everything
she did is in self-defense. I am accusing my partner of blackmail
and I'm accusing my partner of gaslighting. And again,
I it's weird because I understand what she means when she says
it's in self-defense. And I don't like think that this is a universal
situation. I don't think this is something that represents her
character. I believe this is something that was developed specifically
for this relationship uh so that she can uh protect herself from
me. And what she would do uh is basically tell me like when I'm
yelling cuz she's not listening to the words I'm saying while
I'm yelling because you know she's terrified when when I'm like
loud and she gets scared cuz she's afraid I'm going to yell.
So
she tells me uh that I'm not living in reality.
And and the reason I'm really bringing this up is cuz like this
event that just happened really woke me up to the fact that like
you know she would basically say you're not living in reality
and I would agree with her and just like you know try to like
cuz I loved her. I wanted to make it work. So I would just like
listen to what she says about me and then just you know even
if I was her I just I couldn't yell cuz like it was after I had
already yelled that she'd say that. So it was better to just
accept it. So I was constantly being gaslit all the time. And
I'm pretty sure that my partner also felt like she was being
gaslit all the time. Um because again, we just were not a good
match. Um fundamentally, we were a bad match. We had a lot of
stuff in common, but this one aspect like basically again like
resulted in 5 years of gaslighting. And like I went insane, like
completely insane. Like just the feeling that like no one's listening
to me, no one understands me. And once again, a lot of that's
the fact that I'm yelling and I have a partner who can't listen
to me while I'm yelling there. And like yelling is how I get
like naturally my emotions across. So so much of me is being
missed. And then again it's like I feel so slighted that like
I don't give a [__] You know what she what she's
talking about cuz she just Yeah. Is it like impossible to just
wait until you're not fighting and then write down your feelings?
Like you could yell at a piece of paper while you write the stuff
down that you're about to yell and then when you're not in a
case where like she's feeling bad, just like hand the piece of
>> That sounds really gay.
But I don't know.
It's just an idea. It's just an idea, >> you know. She
just basically told me I'm not living in reality. I'm I'm offended,
you know. Um anyways, uh blackmail. So blackmail is maybe the
most most painful thing I've ever gone through in my life. Um
being recorded like without my knowledge, like having a partner
constantly remind me that. Um you know what? Let's take a break.
And uh okay, let me finish my sentence. uh partner. Wait, what
was I talking about? Anyways, um let's take a break and talk
about uh her concerns once again. Like I think that she had every
right to feel the way that she did. I think that the way she
>> Those are some crazy tremors, aren't >> I think
that she had every right to feel >> Yo, that's
wild, isn't it?
>> He's shaking like Aiden when he's in a call with two
women. >> Anyway, dude, I forgot about Aiden. If this guy
had a gaming chair with a back to it, you'd just see that vibrating
all over the place. >> Um, let's take a break and talk
about uh her concerns once again. Like, I think that she had
every right to feel the way that she did. I think that the way
she handled it was really sad and misrepres
$50,000, I'm going to release this. Then it doesn't matter if
she recorded it in self-defense. She's still blackmailing him
with it. >> You have to wait until he actually explains
what what happened before you can say whether or not it's blackmail.
But she didn't say, "Well, I don't know that yet. I'm waiting.
You just got to you got to wait on the information >> representative
of who I am as a person." That's why I even brought it up in
the first place cuz I felt so deeply betrayed cuz again, I've
never had any meaning. Like I've never wanted to do anything
wrong. She did not immediately like I still think about her.
I still care about her and like Yeah. No, my last video was like
vicious and stupid, but also at the same time it was me just
like finally saying, "Oh, I'm just going to like talk and say
whatever." And it turned out this is like I don't know, maybe
the most important experience of my career so far. Yeah. So,
why is it that she's gaslighting me? Why is it that she's Okay,
wait, wait, wait. That's right. I was explaining uh basically
blackmail. So, blackmail is basically like somebody holding you
by a chain at all times. Especially the person that who I like
cared the most about her holding the fact that she has stuff
that she can like destroy my life with over my head is crazy.
And the fact that look it's like I released the video, you know,
and I video was not the cleanest thing in the world, but like
her her first immediate response was the same thing I've been
saying. She'll just like say it's self-defense and then you know
spread all this stuff that feels like again that like the video
I talked about you know the video is me screaming because I'm
being gaslit because I'm not being listened to because I'm yelling
and once again she can't hear a word I'm saying she just hears
yelling she records it she shows it to the cops tells you know
tells them how dangerous I am. They arrest me and it feels like
the biggest betrayal of my life. That's why I brought it up because
like yeah that made me want to kill myself. Um, but once again,
like she truly believed she was in that much danger and I think
that she's completely >> Yeah, that's not Well, so far
that recording is not blackmail cuz it was used directly like
for the police.
>> but I think it could still later on be used as blackmail.
Do you think >> he said like he just said how it was used
as blackmail, right? That like he she used it and is holding
like life destroying material over his head. He's implying that
she's like, "Yeah, and if you like like" like something there's
something where it's like, "If you [__] with me in
some way, I will release this publicly." That when he says she's
holding it over my head, I feel like that's what he means. >> Seems
pretty clear to me. >> Um, hold on. Qual some stuff in
the >> Okay. Okay. >> You go first. You go first.
You go first. I'm going to read this and it's >> I just
I I think if you are if you are verbally abusive, you can't be
like, "Oh, no. How up of you to record it so that I have to like
change my behavior or else.
>> Yeah, I'd say if recording was like care if recording
was like a first but it doesn't sound like like you said 5 years
of this, right? Sounds like it's pretty close to the end of the
5 years. If it was him getting arrested like 7 months ago or
something.
So like it seems like they went through trying to fix it normally
and this was a last ditch like effort to go this is the the behavior
calling the cops showing it to the cops the cops arrest you.
That should be every indication you need to go. Actually, this
behavior is right. When when she shows it to the cops and they
just arrest you and throw you in jail immediately, they don't
like go, "Oh, no. You just have to leave the property." They're
like, "No, you have to go. You have to we have to process you."
Yeah. So, but if if something happens beyond that, I would say
it could it could stretch into blackmail as >> Valid for
that. And that she's allowed to feel however she feels about
the >> Oh, whoops. Whoops. Whoops. I'm going to go back
cuz I was going to read the quality message. After the first
video, she said she was going to release something. Then he did
an apology video and she ended up tweeting that she wasn't going
to release anything and that he never physically abused her.
Then after he released this video, she released the recordings.
Wait, maybe we missed the So, I'm assuming Si is the first video
and then there's an apology video that we've missed here and
then there's this video, right? Okay. >> I think that she's
completely valid for that and that she's allowed to feel however
she feels about the situation. Um, she made a statement. I wanted
to say something because I really just figured it out that like
oh yeah that's right like you know I have been behaving a totally
different way for so long you know once I thought that I lost
my YouTube channel um I really like I really went to a deep >> okay
hold on hold on hold on let's just two minutes >> so I
released a video >> this is after the sweaty video >> um
a few days ago and it was something that was called SI and it
was supposed to be talking about my experience with you know
battling through all this mental health for the last year and
it was a terrible idea. Um the video ended up being extremely
exploitative of my ex because I decided to you know I was like
oh it's my ex-girlfriend but like you know she's a real person
and there are real people being named in this video and so the
entire thing you know comes off as an extreme violation of privacy
and um I can completely understand why people are upset because
it is honestly I think one of the worst things um possibly ever
uploaded to the internet. I am ashamed of it. I feel like I failed
completely like as a person and like this video just highlights
also like all of her concerns, you know, where she's saying that
she's felt this pain, you know, that she recognizes this exploitation
and this feeling of being unsafe around someone like me with
a platform. So, um I'm going to disappear for a year um and see
around this time next year if I'm ready to try again. Okay, so
that's the big thing here. As of July 27th, I'm going to check
out for a year. I said that, but I didn't see where it was said.
So, it's good that we catching this really quickly cuz it is
um yeah, it is important >> because I'm clearly not ready
for this and I am rightfully being called out for honestly just
terrible behavior. Extremely irresponsible behavior and I'd like
to give just like I would like to just say sorry like from the
bottom of my heart from everyone who supports me. It is just
like I'm sorry. Like this was disgusting. There's not a single
justification I have for this. This is the worst thing I've ever
done on YouTube and it will be like seen as that and it should
and I hope that um my ex is able to disconnect herself from this
situation and move on and get help and support like she has been
in the last few days or at least like in terms of support. But
no, like again, I brought this [__] back up. Um,
and it's >> So, apparently the ex also tweeted that she
was going to expose her abuser. So, he's probably kind of panicking
here, right? But I wonder I wonder if that's what he interprets
as blackmail, right? Like, oh, I'm going to expose my abuser
cuz he talked about this and then she said, sorry, he talked
about this. She says, I'm going to expose my abuser and then
he he posts a video apologizing and then probably he's like,
wait, she is really [__] with me. Actually, this
is really [__] And then he makes the video we're
watching before this one. >> It makes perfect sense why
she's so upset and so hurt. But it like even then it took me
a couple of days for it to all click because I was like, "Oh,
you know what's what's so wrong with this video?" You know, I'm
just talking about my own experience. But that's just the thing.
It was all about me. It was selfish. Um, and it turned into a
complete disaster. And yeah, that's all I have to say is that
I'm going away for a year and that this like and that that's
like probably the minimum for something this like that's this
big of a. So I'm I'm sorry. Like I just >> the unfortunate
thing is is whenever somebody makes like a grand claim like this
like I'm going to walk away for a year when realistically it's
it's like if you wanted to walk away from a year or for a year,
you could just walk away. You don't even have to say anything
else, right? You just walk away. When somebody makes the grand
claim like this, they have to hold themselves to it and that's
usually really hard. So I I would say most people who are capable
of actually doing this, like walking away, just wouldn't make
the grand claim in the first place. They would never say I'm
leaving for a year or I'm never coming back or anything like
that, >> Yeah, probably not. >> So, I I feel like
when you do this, it uh it makes a like I I would have looked
at this and gone, "Yeah, there's no shot." It's like Darius saying
he's never getting back to with together with Zena again. It's
like you could just not do it. You don't even have to say you're
never doing it. You don't have to say, "Oh, you owe everybody
$1,000 each in chat if they if you get back together." It's like
not You don't have to do it. Just like not get back together
and that's fine. I let everybody down, you know, like >> No,
I believe Darius and Zen every time they say that >> you
are one of my
This is Rose Malay's video, but I don't want to watch this yet.
So, we've got 2 minutes left in this. So, timeline
um
SI she tweets she's going to expose her abuser apology video
from Brad that we just watched. Then Brad, then um she tweets
that she's going to hold off. And then this video from Brad where
he says, "She's actually blackmailing me and holding this over
my head." >> Depression. Like, ask anyone. But like the
the thing is that really made me make this video is that it just
kept getting worse and like in in really weird and interesting
ways where people are like really showing their character around
me and I'm just like, "Huh?" You know, and I'm I'm absolutely
hurt by it. But um all I have left right now are people who I
could spend a whole day talking to, which you know what, I'll
take that. And by the way, entire internet for believing everything
you read at face value. Uh just know I don't blame you. All right?
Because I would do the same. And that's just literally this culture.
All right? So, you know, this is me literally saying we are both
victims of each other, you know, and that the relationship like
dissolved in a way that that I thought felt extremely unfair,
but I can see like why she was as terrified as she was. But the
reality is once again like this is not a problem around people
who are like me. It just happens to be the circle I have, you
know, all the people who are around me who are just like tuned
differently. You know what I mean? >> Yeah, it was me cracking
my knuckles.
>> I mean, and I did I did hurt them, but like once again,
I didn't mean to hurt anybody. So, like it really >> hurt
sometimes, >> you know, not my fault as much as it is,
you know, like I don't know. Whatever. Hopefully this clears
it up, but knowing the internet probably won't and I don't really
care. Sorry for not keeping up with the two-year rule, but I
just I don't know. Maybe I just was like like I could I guess
I could have waited a little longer. I'm probably still taking
a break, but I'm making music like all day. Like I'm just in
the studio, dude. Creating crazy stuff. Listen to this. All right.
All right. I got to click this
video on. >> Does she actually play it? >> Well,
guess you'll have to wait till next time. Peace. >> Okay.
All right. Peace.
Okay. So, that's the video he releases. Then she drops the full
audio.
The full audio is not this one. There's like a longer audio than
this. There's like a 10-minute audio that we've opened up here.
Let me Oh, it's right here. I don't know if I'm going to do this
right now. Okay. I don't know if I'm going to do this. This is
like I don't know if I'm going to do this right now.
Maybe we'll watch it after. But okay. So, don't cut us. Dude,
it's just going to be him screaming at her like one-sidedly.
If she released it, it's going to be like super one-sided. It's
going to be tough. >> My own head. >> Yeah. I'll
listen. Hold on.
>> Oh, hold on. I'm getting audio clicks. Yeah, I'm getting
Hold on. I >> ordering 7-Eleven. What is What is the best
chocolate bar to get?
>> Okay. Oh, sorry, Cherry.
My headphones weren't coming back. I talked over you, didn't
I? >> Yeah, I think so. What's the best chocolate to get?
>> I don't know. Fudge
>> Oh, chocolate bar. >> Babe Ruth. Does anybody
in the world eat Babe Ruth's?
I dude I can't do I can't do chocolate bars anymore.
I I think like basically all foods once like pie fructose corn
syrup became like a thing are awful. Like all mass produced >> I'm
PMSing so I need it.
Speaking of little Brad taste move there information nobody asked
for cherry. >> Isn't it obvious?
>> It's like 3:00 a.m. I'm ordering
>> But okay. All right.
while I'm >> brushing my dogs. I'm just thinking and you
are asking me what I'm thinking about and not letting me not
tell you. You are not letting me have privacy in my own [__]
>> Like that's literally what just happened. Like I'm sitting
here brushing >> I'm going to fill up a bowl. You do whatever
it is you usually do.
>> Uh there's the weed addiction. >> And uh >> what
is he filling the bowl with? Cheerios or >> We'll take
it from there. I'm rushing my >> and you think that you
are entitled to know what is happening in my brain and you are
not. >> I'm just right and you're lying.
>> Go on. >> What am I lying about? Can you tell
me if you're going to accuse me of lying? Can you tell me what
I'm lying about? >> What am I lying about? >> What
are you thinking about? >> You're I'm lying about what
I'm thinking
>> And you know that. How? >> Cuz I just know. Because
I've been with you for 5 years. >> Because you just know
that I'm lying for 5 years. That's an important
actually had to deal with your >> You're obviously lying.
You're obviously lying to me right now. I just know.
>> I've actually had to deal with your >> So you
you had to deal with my for 5 years. So you know exactly what
I'm >> going to throw it on to me. Oh, but I've had to
deal with your Look at you, Nia. You're full of >> Okay,
so I'm sorry. So wait, so you accuse me of lying? What am I lying
about? You still haven't like outright said what I'm lying about.
If you're going to call me a liar, then >> I mean, you
don't need to either. >> I will say uh this starts recording
when he's not abusing her, right? That is a little concerning
to me, right? That that does seem a little concerning that it
it
recording. >> Well, with the one minute recording that
like I don't he's not >> It's concerning the way people
are clipping it. I feel like the fact that it exists with without
him being uh abusive first is good, right? because then you know
it's not out of context.
>> Well, it's better for context, but it also is concerning
that like she was Why was she recording already before they were
really in a fight? Like, do we believe that she's fully deescalating
here or is she trying to get like is she thinking, "Oh, he usually
goes off like >> Well, okay. She she just said that
she said, "How am I lying? Where am I lying?" So, there's a chance
that she's feeling gas lit already and it's like dja vu.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm saying I'm now looking for where
she's going to be deescalating, right? So, if she expects a fight's
coming and she's got the wherewithal to start recording, I feel
like I'm expecting also deescalation here, which >> Do
you expect her to deescalate if he's accusing her of lying and
she hasn't?
>> Um, I I would not expect her to. So, she doesn't have
to say she was lying. I would expect her to just not like raise
the temperature. But I think probably if she's not going to if
she's not going to agree with him that he like he's making >> like
he's mind reading, right? So I'm imagining that if he's already
at the point where he's saying that, he's probably not far away
from yelling either, right? Like if you're willing to say, "No,
no, no. I know you better than you know yourself." So you you
say you're not lying, but I know you're lying. You probably have
a good idea, I think, that he's not far away from starting to
scream. Yeah. Anyway, >> what am I lying about? You still
haven't like outright said what I'm lying about. If you're going
to call me a liar, then >> I mean, you don't need Tina.
There's so >> So, what I'm going to tell you is that I'm
not lying about anything. I'm sitting here. >> You start
with telling me one thing you have lied about. What have you
lied to me about here? >> What have I lied to you about?
>> I can think of times where you have mistakenly
lied.
>> I've said you've lied and no matter what I've said,
you wouldn't accept that you lied to me. So, you're a liar and
you can't accept it. So if someone >> which is the worst
combination I think I've ever witnessed in a partner. >> So
if someone unknowingly says something that isn't true where they
don't know >> and they can't accept when somebody corrects
them then they're full of >> and when somebody can't listen
when their partner tells them
>> and actually just deflects it and makes their life hell,
>> then that's and then you're a terrible lying partner
who's emotionally abusive. Do you want to continue? So if you
say something to me, if I just >> No, if you want to be
combative, we can continue being combative because clearly you
are not paying enough attention to this conversation. >> I
just don't understand. So >> how about you stop doing what
you're doing with the dogs, look at me in the eyes, and just
tell me the truth, Tina. >> What the truth about what?
>> You tell me. >> Okay. So
>> being a sarcastic
dude. Sorry. I could as soon as he cut in there, I started going
to pause.
And dude, that was a great pause timing.
How about you tell me that she starts answering, she gets a half
second into her answer without being a sarcastic
>> Okay. Okay, Brad. All right.
>> You tell me. >> Okay. So, if I >> without
being a sarcastic,
look at me in the eyes and tell me the truth. >> So, I
have, >> by the way, none of this is really that funny.
Uh, I laugh to get through the pain, okay? It's it like obviously
it's not great. I'm just laughing because it's like pretty ridiculous
to get this >> Me eyes Tina >> accidentally lied
to you
>> in the >> he says as he keeps laughing. >> I'm
sorry but the none of this is funny you guys.
>> None of this is funny.
>> So I have >> in the eyes Tina >> accidentally
lied to you before. Well, I have like mistakenly given you sorry
I have mistakenly given you incorrect information and I
don't mistakenly given giving incorrect information is not lying
and I am sorry. >> So if that's not an example then try
again an example where you lie to me. >> I don't know that
I took the dogs out and I hadn't yet. >> Uh I don't know
sometime at some point I I was like yep doing it right now and
then I didn't do it for another half an hour or something. >> So
you lied to me and you didn't even remember it.
You don't even remember lie about the dogs that I took care of.
>> So it meant nothing to you. It was just a little white
lie about the dogs. >> I'm saying I'm sure that you're
so used to throwing white lies at me. You don't even recognize
this. >> No, that's not true. I just don't >> There's
just There's so many white lies, Tina. It's like if they're all
white lies, then none of them are right. >> I don't What
am I lying to you about? I like I don't know what you're telling
me. I'm lying to you about >> what's happening in my own
brain. That's not fair. My own brain. You're not entitled to
know that
I'm an individual. If I don't have a safe place within my own
head, >> okay, Tina, I'm your partner in 5 years. And if
you uh don't respect me as an individual, then you can honest
to God get the out of my house. >> Our both of our names
are on the lease.
So that's not going to happen. And also,
>> you are not >> I'm going to call the police. >> I
will get you out of here. I will make a story up. I will get
you out of here.
>> I will make a story up. >> That's a behavior that
I haven't heard pointed out is making threats like that. That's
really bad. That is nothing to do with lying. He is not even
lying yet. Right. Or sorry, that is why did I say lying? That
has nothing to do with yelling. He's not even yelling yet. Right.
Like he said, "Oh my whole problem is yelling. That is a threat
that's totally outside of the yelling pattern of behavior. I'm
just going to make something up to the cops. I'm going to call
the cops and I'm going to just make something up about you. >> Knowing
full and well that her name is on the lease and she has a right
to be there. That's crazy. >> Cuz she does say, "Yeah,
you can't kick me out. I'm on the lease." >> Our names
are on the lease. So, you will not be doing that.
>> I will say my partner has been emotionally abusive and
I have asked her to leave many times. And despite the fact that
I have no support system, she has refused to leave and has continued
to emotionally abuse me. I need her to get out for at least a
day. I need spate and she refuses. Can you please escort my partner
somewhere else so that I can have some mental peace >> for
a whole day? >> Can he not go for a walk? >> Ma'am,
please come with us to the holiday in. Your husband, your partner
needs a break. Ma'am, please come with us. What are you going
to do?
>> I'm going to call you done.
>> Am I >> done?
Can I? Yeah, we'll we'll take your wife to the movies. You you
relax,
>> Actually, you know, I'll give you peace if I'm allowed
to be quiet. Am I allowed to be quiet? Or do I have to share
what's going on in my brain? >> Wow. So, now that you actually
know that you need to be quiet, it's also my >> Can I be
quiet? >> Can you stop blaming me for >> Can I be
quiet without you crying about what's going on? What I'm thinking?
>> Can you stop being a horrific partner? Can you look
at me in the eyes? Can you treat me like a person? Can you treat
me like someone who's at your level and not someone who you can
manipulate? >> I
you
my brain >> and you will destroy me. >> I just want
>> you will do anything. >> I just want to be able
to think quietly while I brush my dogs. I just want to be able
to quietly reflect on my life while I brush my dogs without you
asking what I'm thinking about and crying it out of me and thinking
you're entitled to know what I'm thinking about. You're not.
>> I'm not even your partner. >> You're not treating
me like a partner.
You're looking around looking for excuses, Tina. I literally
am watching. >> Oh man, I can't believe he passed this
off or described this as just him yelling. It's not yelling,
right? That's not like the prime. You can tell she's already
wherever she gets to in her head with the yelling, she's already
getting there. It's like the tone. It's like the It's the tone
and like direction he's taking the conversation where he's not
giving her like a way out and he's constantly getting like more
and more
like the way he speaks. I feel like that's what's getting to
her. I don't think it's the volume at all. He paints it as the
volume because the volume can't be like intentful, right? Or
the volume can be unintentional,
but this can't really be. This is like way way different than
the volume of your voice, right? We'll pull it back so you can
see what I mean. Like you are evil. Like when you use the the
affectation in your voice to to like communicate, I feel like
that is what's going through >> and prying it out of me
and thinking you're entitled to know what I'm thinking about.
You're not. >> I'm not even your partner. You don't. >> You're
not treating me like a partner. >> You're looking around
looking for excuses, Tina. I literally am watching your body
language. >> I can't look in your eyes. >> You look
like one of those freaks on the interrogation videos. >> I
can't look in your eye. >> Every single thing you're doing
is full
>> You're literally acting like the criminals there, Tina.
Like every action. I could record it.
>> The JCS shout out is kind of crazy. Like Tina's looking
to the left while immediately Oh, he asks a question and her
eyes are moving around as she's >> Is that the JCS impression?
Why not? >> She does. No. Oh, no you don't.
>> You are a lying manipulative person. >> You have
trouble. >> And you
>> um this is a thing that I notice happens a lot
um between people who fight. I have like a lot of family members
who fight like this where like one person will make themselves
small and you can tell somebody somebody's the like proclivity
to me. >> I hate that.
>> Yeah. Like I think um and one person will like fill
the space, right? So they'll become like bigger. They'll like
become more intrusive because the other person's retreating.
Um that can be like kind of a natural pattern that happens obviously.
This sounds horrible, man. I don't I feel like I experienced
that um watching people's on YouTube, but growing up, maybe it's
the half Dominican, half Italian, everybody yells at each other.
There is no quiet,
you know, tucked away person. >> Yeah, this is rough. I
see what he's saying about the the poor match or whatever cuz
I do think there's a there's a possibility that like this doesn't
get anywhere near as bad with somebody who's willing to like
yell and get like Fiery back, right? is the fact that she's like
withdrawing and retreating and he is getting like more and more
invasive. Like I I feel like I can visualize just from this conversation
how he's getting like closer and more in her face while she tries
to like avoid eye contact and pull back from him. >> Like
I realize that's adding something. It's a narration, but I feel
like I can just feel it in the voices like he is getting bigger.
He is moving closer to her. He's getting more in her face while
he talks down to her. >> Yeah. I don't know. >> My
house. >> Yeah. And I just want to just real quick cuz
somebody said just admit you think it's like fake woman behavior
or something. I don't think it's fake from her. I think there
are genuinely like people who shut down. I just don't think it's
always the case where one person shuts down. >> And I think
well I I think the shutting down thing isn't necessarily like
a good or like I it sounds crazy but the shutting down thing
can be weaponized,
>> Like it definitely can. I don't see that happening here.
I don't think that's happening here. >> Um, and I've been
I've been listening to it or like worried about that being the
case. Well, I I am serious that it can be. It's not. It's not
in this case. It's probably extremely rare, but it can be. It
totally can be, but um I've been listening for it here and she
sounds like genuinely distressed and upset.
because she does know. Oh, no you don't. Tina, you >> are
a lying manipulative person. I have >> and you need to
get out of my house. >> I have trouble with eye contact.
I do. >> I am going to call the cops >> if you don't
stop lying to me, Tina, right now. This is it. Are you done?
>> What am I lying about? >> All right. >> What
am I lying to you about? >> All right. Well, you got to
hide the >> I'm not going to >> Sorry, that just
hit me. >> We're both on a police. That doesn't >> Well,
if I want to call the cops and make something up about you, I'm
going to have to hide the weed, I guess. >> Work.
Yeah, it does. I'm going to say my partner is emotionally abusing
me and I have asked for space endlessly and I have no support
system. I moved out here for her and I'm trapped. >> Man,
this is like going to go so like you almost have a not almost,
you have a really hard time feeling bad for him when you know
that the cops got called and she gave them them the recording
and they arrested him. It's like, dude, I can't even really feel
bad for you. You're like describing what you're going to tell
them, which is not true, at least from this recording. And
I don't know, it's pretty crazy why they cut the audio. The full
audio is so much worse. Um, I think it's like definitely not
better. Like this is pretty bad. This is the thing about this
is it takes away from his excuse of like I have rage issues,
right? I don't think this is like a rage issue. This is like
a like he's actually fairly calm for a lot of this talk. Like
he's not he's not like misspeaking. He's not getting he's not
like cutting himself off. He's not biting his tongue in any way.
He's not like doing anything that you would expect somebody who's
like super raging out to be doing. Screaming. He's kind of just
like meticulously breaking her down. So that's I don't know.
It's very weird. Very odd to me. I had another
uh I think she sounds genuine now, but at the start it sounded
like she was goating him on to me. Well, I don't know if it was
goating
and I that's what I right off the bat I was listening for this
like I'm looking for her to like continue to escalate
but I'm not hearing the escalations
>> face endlessly and I have no support system. I moved
out here for her. >> Oh, the other thing my house constantly.
That's the thing that was annoying. Yes. Knowing they're both
on the lease and going my house, my house, my house. That is
another textbook like controlling or manipulative behavior. You
pay for this person's existence. It's always your house. is never
our house. That's like another that's bad, right? If you if you're
going to have a partner that lives with you and you tell them
like, "Oh, you should be happy. Like, we lived we we're both
on the lease or whatever." You put her on the lease. You do all
this stuff. You can't then use that in an argument. You can't
use that in a fight. I think that's probably pretty >> and
I'm trapped and I need space. She has her mother's house. I need
help. >> My mom is not. You can't push me out of my own.
>> You are one of my abusers. So, I can damn right do that
to you. I can kick you the [__] out of here for what
the [__] you've done to me. >> You destroyed
me. >> What? How? All I've ever wanted is >> Stop
lying to me for once. Look at me in the eyes and stop lying to
me. Stop being such a wimp. >> All I've ever >> Look
at me and accept what you have done to me. Do you see what I've
become? >> That line goes so hard.
That go it just goes so hard. You me. You promised me everything.
You lied to me. Look at me. The [__] eyes
again. Look at me.
Tell me. Tell me. Tell me what the you just said. Tell me. Get
out of my house. >> Get out of my [__] house.
>> Don't do it. Don't do it. Don't. Don't. >> You're
I'm You're like I'm >> You are evil.
But you're evil.
>> Oh, we're going to listen to the song. Captain C3 319.
>> There's a song.
>> He
after the audio got released or possibly just after his video.
I think it's after the audio though. I believe he dropped a diss
track on his former
>> Get the out of here. >> It's a 45minut stream
of him
>> And it's a freestyle. It's him like freestyling and
recording it. Like he makes it. Well, he I think he is good at
making music. He freestyled for 45 minutes about it. You can
tell it's off the dome.
>> All right. Well, >> that means it's bad.
>> I am very excited. Yes, I'm very excited. Sorry, I have
so many tabs open though. Close chat. Close this. Close this.
Close this. Not this. >> Up, down, left, right, cheek.
>> We're on Reddit.
>> okay. The rest is just her crying. I Sorry. If you want
that, you go to someone else's YouTube or that like >> listen
to women crying for like a minute and a half. Okay. >> I'm
good with I'm good with this.
>> I'm good. I'm good. I'm good.
It's time. It's time. This is what we've been doing the whole
stream for. It's this part right now. Okay.
>> I feel
like no more pressure is going to show up because the people
left forever. And you know what? I'm not going to pretend like
this to like
a couple.
>> Wait, wait, wait. This is actually his dude. His voice
is so low over the rest of it.
>> Look, I don't want to mix words. All right, but I'm
a nerd.
>> Does he fix his audio? Yeah, he fixes audio levels at
some point.
>> All right.
December, too. >> I'm sorry. I'm going to skip until we
get better audio levels.
>> But they looking like Gary Buucy.
>> Looking like Gary Buucy. Okay. Look at who came in to
draw the line. He doesn't talk about his relationship until at
least
20 minutes, I think. Okay. Well,
>> she was from Islam.
>> Stop it. >> Oh my god. That >> Stop it.
>> Stop it. What? Stop what >> did he No, I'm already
offended. That's a Nikki track. >> Oh, is it? >> It's
like a joke. And it's like everything that I've done doesn't
matter. And it's like they putting me on a flat like Oh, man.
We have to cancel him.
Yeah, man. All they doing is slicing me, man. I ain't
where I'm supposed to be. Yeah. Why? Cuz
No, I'm not supposed to have these damn friends who say that
they friends. I feel like Riby at the end of the one episode
of the regular show. Man, you Oh my god, that's so loud. I really
hope nobody heard it. I did not do that on purpose.
Black Beetles is a song that I could play, but what else can
I say? I'm about to bring back studio. Yeah. Got a in a studio.
Yeah. Sing at studio.
Hey, I don't know what that means, but I'm curious.
Yeah. Yeah. That's what it is, man. Yeah, man. She took the kids,
man. Yeah. You just know it is, man. >> They had kids.
She >> I assume she means like a He means like a cat or
something. I'm guessing
>> [__] Somebody tell me what song this is.
Why can't I remember what song this >> Feeling myself.
Nicki Minaj and Beyonce. >> Oh, I think so. >> Why?
Oh, it's right there. Kill. I thought you knew some Jesus.
>> I was almost impressed with you. >> No, I don't
know anything about that
>> Man,
she was Islam.
Yeah, they don't know what I is saying. Look, she came over.
Trust me, it's on. Cam, look, I'm making a sequel. That's what
I'm saying. Yeah, she was my >> I didn't mean it like that.
Shut the [__] up. >> Yeah. No, we know what
you meant. >> Yeah.
Yeah.
Now listen, I don't know what he saw, but let's let him talk
about chainsaw. They don't want to test the beat out.
Why? What I say? They got a bleed out. Oh man. They don't know
what they have now. Your vision turning to now.
I feel like I am the only child.
Told mama I'm the only wife.
I just want to see you happy and smile.
Feel like I was the only child. Why? I need to call my other
family.
>> Looking forward to this. >> Look, if I talk to
the man, be proud of
Uh well he just he's like a month out of five months of rehab,
isn't he? So hopefully not. >> So he is >> he's he
relapsed. I feel like if if he relapsed and the music is still
it's a problem. Okay. Your best music should come after a major
relapse. No. >> I mean look how small his eyes are. He's
>> Okay. Cuz I seem to be handling life sloppily.
I'm telling you bad she sloppy. She on top.
But let me stay on topic. Yeah, bad matter at Hot Topic. Yeah.
Wo crap. Your ass told me to stop it. Hey, it's a bad time to
bring this up, man. But this is
That happens. But this is real.
Okay. No, don't cancel him. Don't cancel him. Let him stay. Let
him stay. That's like That's like moral times 10 right there,
isn't it? Like moral stayed up. >> No, he hasn't even said
a slur yet, >> dude. No, no, no. I'm talking about moral's
original allegations. We moral like he's just like, "Yeah, I
did. I did message that 17-year-old. Yeah, I did flirt with her
and he won." Okay, but this guy's like, "Yeah, I I did grab this
[__] on Hot Topic. She told me to
>> It's very Maxcoded. That's like a max >> We're
going for it again.
But let me stay on topic. Yeah, babe. Met her at Hot Topic. Yeah.
Whoa. Crapped your ass on me. Stop it. Hey, it's a bad time to
bring this up, man. But this is real stuff that happened and
I ain't
right.
>> That just happened to be my future wife. She just don't
know it yet. Man, I say these things online. You know, I been
a sweat. But listen, no one's associated with me anymore. But
truthfully, Karen, they ass it really wasn't chore. So that's
something I really can't ignore the
I just can't ignore.
they ready.
>> Yo B,
>> Yeah. No.
>> Why not? >> Cuz he he's not be He's not Beyonce.
Why did he play that part? I'm offended. >> He could be
Beyonce. He's about to He's about to drop some bars right now.
He's about to go hard. Okay, this is going to be great. >> White
men on the internet need to be >> It can't be. The woman
hot topic couldn't stop him. What chance do you >> Ready
for what? No, she is not a
I promise I was not looking at her butt. As she talked to me,
I had to say what? Cuz enough is enough.
I feel like I'm out of this world. This [__] is tough.
Think that it's a joke. Yeah. Other days recorded. Yeah, that's
pretty bad. But listen, got bags under my eyes cuz I'm so vic
ruining my own enterprise.
Yeah,
this is no surprise to me. This about as predictable as the rise
of me. Boom. Oh, they didn't see it. Hey. Yeah,
I got good. I'm good at plumbing.
Yeah, listen. My feelings. I'm really still numbing. Ma had to
pour out the bottle. Ain't that something? But they pulling at
my chain, but now I'm not
my come back. That's something they ain't want. Oh, they coming
back. Oh, ain't that some? It's almost like they forgot which
they was jumping. Yeah.
>> [__] Dr. Seuss ass rapper.
>> I'm feeling myself. I'm feeling I'm feeling myself.
I'm feeling myself. I'm feeling myself.
>> I have no Does anybody know what he's doing to like
>> He's trying to get inspiration. I don't >> I don't
I don't even know how the any of this is working. I have no idea
what's going on on this screen at all. I can tell there's music
being Yeah. Well, there's four different tracks that he's like
cutting pieces out of and using at the same time. But is he looping
the sections he has highlighted from each or like he has this
section highlighted. Are these just looping to create the beat
for him or something?
They're okay. He's looping samples. Okay. Okay. Okay. Got it.
Got it. >> Look, I ain't playing no. I'm making crazy sounds,
tearing down crazy times.
Plus, I just watched addict.
Yeah. And it might be better than all of our guests are the m.
But it's possible they all t the best. Let's not pretend. Yeah.
And I don't think that his legacy will end.
Yeah. You know what the I'm saying?
Look, they don't want to see a response. They want it to never
come and they want it to come in seconds at the same time. Just
like, "Yo, man, it's game time, man. You know what I'm saying,
man? You know I ain't lying when I say that she'd be bending
over like she was picking up the mail, but she probably be picking
up the mail." Wait, no, that's not what I'm trying to sell. Oh
[__] man. I'm not gay if you couldn't tell. Huh?
But I watched Brokeback Mountain and I ain't gonna lie. Never
thought I love a movie about a guy.
Couldn't make this up. If I tried, if I said I didn't like the
movie, I would be
No,
really, it's amazing. Makes me wonder why the gays don't take
a vacation. They too busy protecting themselves. Got to go take
some time for the shelves. Man, I find the same words. So if
I have to clarify it too, that doesn't hair, doesn't solve anything.
Yeah.
Doesn't mean anything.
This is the fees I bring. Bring them to the table. Do this off
they don't now they they wouldn't be able see even when I be
that [__] is still a f cuz it even all the people
who disable cuz uh you ain't nothing what I did. That don't make
sense. But God, please forgive a bad.
That's how I live. Yeah. You do not exist.
It's your bad [__] that I just pissed. No, I'm not
talking on the lips. Yeah,
my list. Yeah. And my game do exist.
Yeah.
I could not resist. Haters so mad they trying to put me on a
list. Yeah. I heard about the whole fun fiasco. You listen to
lupe fiasco.
Yeah, you too busy focusing on my cash flow. Yeah, you should
focus about the size of your ass. Look, I know what I said. I'd
rather release the statement than be dead. I don't really give
a what I said. Look, they I write it in land. They excited to
give me some.
It's like I'm on vacation,
man. I can't even give them an illustration
cuz they wouldn't understand what I'm saying.
Every day is like a vacation. And sure, I took advantage of my
wealth, but truthfully, I gave some to myself.
I gave some advantages to myself that you will never have. Oh,
man. You'll just be never glad. And I just see Chris faces on
the phone. Yeah, you can't leave that [__] alone.
Picking up the ring tone. Yeah, in jail I used to sing song.
Now I have to write my wrong. Bad [__] with the tightest.
Yeah, they just hating. They just hate. >> This guy just
loves talking about bad all the time.
>> And vacation. He's like he is feeling >> I'll
be honest. This like a thousand times better than I could do.
So, you know, I don't I I can't talk that much.
There's no way. You can't think of more than five like sentences
that rhyme.
>> Stop it. >> I will not.
>> You could just plagiarize and do better than this. >> I
don't think so. >> Cuz I'm They just hating cuz I'm so
impatient. It's like, man, I've been sitting here patiently waiting
and they just treating me like my time doesn't matter. Got a
bad in the bladder.
That really did not turn left, but it's okay. Okay, because I'm
really turnurning the batter. I'm really making cakes. I'm really
making rhymes. And haters, they so mad that it's game time. That
means time to step up to the plate. Have you ever done something
that's truly great? Nah, you just like to talk a lot. Oh man,
bad [__] in my parking spot. I told the car out my
place and then I spit in her face. This is a true story. Real.
They don't know how I feel. It's like I don't even know how to
appeal. But no, I can't. Cuz listen, I could say it, but no,
I I sh. I meant to stay like in a medieval way.
Watch Broke Peck Mountain. I'm a medieval gay. Look, I don't
even know what to say. It's like my rhyming capabilities went
away. Hey, but still I spring like an AK.
Treat it like it's payday.
Uh yeah, I almost got married. Good to know I didn't get carried
away cuz of >> vacay payday
AK.
I I can see where he's coming from.
>> Wait, run it back a little bit. >> Still I spray
like an AK.
Treat it like it's payday.
Yeah, I almost got married. Good to know I didn't get carried
away because of the [__] that she would say just
to ruin my day. My god telling you it's like blackmail on my
iPod on repeat man. She was letting people think that I beat
her just so that she can stay out of it. Oh man, I really hope
she feels proud of it. [__] ridiculous
I put up with bad [__] Look, get my nuts kissed.
Then I'm drinking a sun kiss. Yeah. Hold the >> Yeah, I'm
pulling back just to say so it seems like when she said I'm going
to out my abuser, he feels like he's getting blackmailed and
sort of being painted as like a physical abuser.
>> Just for the
people out there who are >> He thinks what? It's worse
if he's a physical abuser than if he's like emotionally abusive.
>> Yeah. Like he thinks it's like oh it's so much worse.
And realistically,
dude, that was that was rough to listen to. Anyway,
>> this I put ugly bad look. Getting my nuts kissed, then
I'm drinking a sun kissed. Yeah, told the story she was,
man. They just can't handle it. Wearing these sandals, [__]
Why? Cuz I'm looking like Jesus in this. And I'm saying, "God,
please. I need Jesus in this." But he said, "Stop cursing. I
need Jesus in this place." And he said, "That's worth." He said,
"Son, you're a disgrace."
Look, not my proudest moment, but I'll tell you one thing, that
shirt was something. And I go, >> Judge will love this
song. Judge will love all of this video. Yeah.
>> Look, I'm back. I rap like I smoked a pound of crap.
I rap like I'm trying to break my mama's back. Cuz she carrying
my career like a left
dog.
I need a hot dog right now.
The bad needs to pipe down. So what do I do? Oh, simply I yell
at her. That's just what I do. Oh, I'm just a messenger.
Look, a true story. I was yelling at the Yeah, what she do for
me? But ruin my life. Ruining my thinking I'd be her. Wait, no.
That she be my wife. No, I did get that right the first time.
Oh man, I'm just wait. No. No, I didn't. This a hurt line that
I had once, but now really I be looking like a mad dust. And
I be feeling like they stole my credit card. And I remember when
I was selling crack on the prison yard or remember when I used
to avoid the ones whose hard Yeah, that's true. I used to walk
away from it. I'm not Yeah, that's not what I'm trying to say
from it. I'm just saying I don't want my ass on the pavement
in front of all of these other people. Look, doing tricks with
the like evil can. Look, I do what I can. Feel like I'm little
dicky in jail part one cuz that's how they thinking of me too.
Me too move. I'm part of the me too move. Yeah, mad cuz I can't
move my songs. They just might lose. >> It's so long.
We still got 15 minutes.
>> Why is he bringing up so much gay stuff? I don't know.
I don't know. >> Like two things keep coming out. Like
he just keeps spilling about his ex relationship and a lot of
gay thoughts.
>> Is it true that gay men are so emotionally abusive to
women? Maybe there's something here. >> I bet there's like
a trend that it's mostly verbal abuse and no physical
>> Wow.
Wow.
>> My songs they saying they're just not quite music.
What?
Stop. Stop your loose lips. Uh, loose leaf paper in my back pocket.
Haters mad, but they just going to have to sock it.
What can I say? I don't play on the playground. Making all these
gay sounds in the prison yard. Yeah, we back there. Got to tell
you, man. They used to pull back my hair. That's why I cut it
in the first place to try to take my mind away from the worst
place. Yeah. >> Wait, was he actually in jail? Is he trauma
dumping right now? Am I laughing like at an actual
story? >> But they just going to have to suck it.
What can I say? I don't play on the making all these gay sounds
in the prison yard. Yeah, we back there. Got to tell you, man.
They used to pull back my hair. That's why I cut it in the first
place to try to take my mind away from the worst place. Yeah.
Oh, what?
Hold back. >> Getting me to laugh at this guy's >> I
I did not realize I was [__] >> the thing.
Now this gay story >> that was Jesus Christ.
That's really specific to just make up on the fly.
I don't know. >> Nothing makes sense anymore. Let me make
it clear. I don't want this rent anymore. What is that? Oh, that's
the space that I'm taking on YouTube. just trying to get the
money
on bad
keeps quaking around me and they see oh man he's just sleeping
soundly but really man I've been where everyone in the town be
yeah
they go crown >> this is terrible mixing
>> this is so bad >> he's like still vibing so hard
too >> he is high he has to be >> look I ain't playing
around no more they be asking why I sound so po. Why I look like
a hobo? Why I dress like a hobo? All these these questions, man.
Please go slowmo. I'm trying to answer them all right now. I
ain't tall cuz I am. Yeah. And you are a pal. You are a cow and
you look just like well how I do now. But truthfully, I don't
care man. I like how it sound when I call you an animal. Bad
[__] slurping on me like a
Yeah. I eat the like a cannibal. Yeah. Yeah.
Don't even know how to close this off. It's like h when I go
so soft. Oh, I can remember the time it was when I thought that
being me was a crime.
Everyone saying they scared that I'm reverting. Oh [__]
I am. The truth is that they just hurting. Man, is it working?
Don't know if I get my point across. Am I just looking lost again
to everybody out here? Look, let me make it clear. Things are
not how they appear. Yeah, bad [__] Yeah, she took
it in the rear.
Look,
it's true. Listen,
every part of you, you look too. Yeah. I made sure to add that
in. Yeah. So that you know this ain't just babbling. Yeah. That
of my own life on the capping. Uh what the is even happening
to around me? I man I was sleeping soundly. Now they waking me
up with drama. Telling me that for my mama she be crying on the
porch. Damn. I'm going to find a reason to live still. Even though
they want me to take the blue pill. Look, I don't even know what
that means. It sounds cool, but maybe I do. And I don't want
to take it. It sounds cool. Uh to let you know how I made this
beat. Yeah. And hold on. It's almost complete. Just got to >> I
don't want to use this.
>> Look, I'm back. I'm going to add one more ambient drone
to the track. See, cuz this one ended. Uh, and I can't pretend
that this ain't going to make this feel completely different.
Uh, there it is. Listen,
>> nut sucker. Nut tucker, too. You too. Yeah. Oh, I said
that already. Well, you needed to remind us. Yeah. Bad looking
at two behind us.
That's just how it go. Haters mad. Think I've gone slow. thinking
I don't know what I'm doing.
Black music ain't the [__] I'm pursuing.
I'm thinking, "Oh, stick to music videos." Oh, sorry. I mean,
stick to getting hoes.
>> All right, now it's getting real. They is mad at me
because I see
Look, look around. I just don't know who to it's. It's like man
all these people and I used thinking was my friends but n I guess
that all good things and
unless he's pretend from the very thought yeah I asked him from
my heart please tell me do you look at me it's just like Kevin
Hart getting entertained a leg sprainer for your enjoyment oh
man I got another guy trying to avoid employment
yeah well that's just how it goes bad [__] he imported
from Mexico yeah Oh, that's where the Lexus go. Hey,
I got the Texas [__] but I can't drop no names yet.
Why? Because I still want to write insane checks
and they they coming after
I starting badly. That's what they claim. They say that I've
been running >> Wait, wait, hold on. Did he look off to
the side to see his parents are going to open his door? >> They
coming after me. He like shoulder checked.
Oh. assault a battery against my girl. You know the one I love,
the one who's my entire world and she believes this. Don't know
how she's deceived herself into this. But really, no, I see it.
See, here's the reality. It's called h the having a platform
mentality. See, people think that it's the thing that you should
strive for. Nah, man. It was the thing I was no longer going
to be alive for.
Oh, man. Working 5 to 4. Yeah, man. What a chore. I think I'd
rather see what life is like if I think I'd rather just end it
right now. Yeah. So, I said it out loud. I recorded a 20 minutes
note man. I wish I could remember the quotes, man. But just understand
that it really wasn't gross, man. It was honest. I said, "Man,
this is why I wasn't honest. Maybe I should look around more.
Maybe I focus on the sound more." Oh, sorry not to sound poor,
but yeah, I need it, girl. Can I please have it? [__]
I'm like a fiend in a drug addict. Yeah, I need this [__]
Got to like a rabbit,
man. These balls I'm spitting promise you this [__]
will be a bad habit. No, let me make that clear. It will be a
bad habit. And h I will do whatever I have it. Cuz I make the
beats, I make the rhymes, and need no help. See people thinking
that they understand me better than myself.
[__] ridiculous there. I said it again. Hey, bad
[__] ain't even pretend.
Look, she was maybe a 10
and she ain't even a friend, bro. Well, none of them are. Remember
when we was sitting together in the car? Man, I said, "Wow, you
guys are great for this, man. My life I felt I paid for this.
like everybody's looking at me like I'm some guy and it makes
me feel like I want to die. But I could not talk to people. Felt
like a great evil. These people swoop in and said, "Man, you
are us." And I said, "Man, it's like these people I trust." And
the next thing I know, this man who's robust says, "Huh, man,
see I'm the leader of the group." And I say I should Yeah. Turn
your whole life into Huh? Just cuz I believe that I'm trying
to recoup. Ridiculous. Once again, these people, they think that
they owe me or I owe me. My god. It's like I owe them a drink.
Hey, bad [__] She a twink. Dang, you know what it
is. Had to show her the not in front of her kids. Please. That's
not why I visited.
shed in a residence bad. I'm throwing the president.
Yeah. Bad needs the bad looking for some evidence. Look. Is it
ever this? Is it ever as bad as they say it is. See, that's what
this [__] got me thinking. I've been like, I quit
drinking, by the way. Now I couldn't even do it anymore. It's
like, wow, man.
Don't know. It's like I have a child, man. It's like I'm trying
to do something good, you know, instead of just giving back to
the hood and the hood for me in a I'm not a racist. The
>> He's giving back to the hood. He's giving back >> instead
of just giving back to the hood and the hood for me in a I'm
not a racist way. I'm trying to say it's the internet. Do you
know what I'm getting to yet? Look, I'm trying to say this place
is >> Yeah, we have to break that down. We need to analyze
that. He said he wants to do something good instead of just giving
back to the hood >> it anymore. It's like wow man. Don't
know. It's like I have a child, man. It's like I'm trying to
do something good, you know? Instead of just giving back to the
hood. >> Trying to do something good instead of just giving
back to the hood. And by hood, I don't mean hood in a racist
way. Is that the next bar? >> And the hood. I mean in a
not a racist way. I'm trying to
>> He meant in a racist way. >> The hood. and the
hood. I mean, in a not a racist way. I'm trying to say it's the
internet. Do you know what I'm getting to yet? Look, I'm trying.
>> Oh, we're getting there. We're getting >> The
hood is the internet. He doesn't just want to get back to the
internet. >> Say this place is a slump. I'm saying the
internet truthfully looks like the whole pie, but really it's
just crumbs. It's full of fat bums
living. Something's wrong with the way the system is going, man.
My bank account really is grow. Got to hit the hit the drone
again. Got a bad she got me in the zone again. >> This
guy in bad. I hate this horn. Is there a horn like this in Spongebob?
>> A [__]
I [__] But that's just how it is man. When you be
in the man. Hold on. Pop quiz man. Sorry. What the you is saying
mad [__] That's all I hear, man. It's a bunch of
mad [__] It's like I'm surrounded by this bad [__]
I used to be the source of all magic, man. I made some projects,
they were mad. And man, I made this video. It was massive. And
man, I did so much good to everyone. I tried to do something
nice, but here I've come. Look, it's like, wow, look how it's
all falling down. I must be a completely different guy. Wow.
It's like I didn't even try to do good in this world. I just
beat a girl. Yeah, that's all it is. Just really imagine if they
could truly have my business be in my shoes. Understand the pain
that I felt. Really felt like I couldn't say nothing else. Yeah.
Talked over so much. The only way to overcome it is to Yeah.
Yeah. And so that's what I did if you couldn't tell by the [__]
that she saying on the end as well. Yeah. Look, things ain't
going well for me. As you can tell from me, baby know she paying
bail for me. Yeah, she miss my company. Yeah, I'm about to rhyme
that with comfort me. Yeah, she want to comfort me. Yeah, it's
like, hold on. Is there room for three? I'm like, huh, let me
check again. Yeah, sorry. Let me just inspect again. I had to
look another time if you notice what I mean. Cuz I know I keep
my whip clean. Uh, that's where the party goes. That's where
I play my games. Haters mad at me cuz they ain't listen to this
crazy. >> Okay, banan gummy verse. >> No. My gummy
verse now.
>> No. Can somebody chop this up? >> What do you
mean chop this up? >> We need We need somebody cuz 45 minutes
that's not a song. Okay. Nothing that's 45 minutes long is ever
going to go viral. But if somebody chops this up and makes it
go viral, I feel like 100% with the backstory behind it, Kanye
would reach out to this dude to make a track with him. >> Kanye
might already do it. Okay. Kanye is a visionary. Kanye can see
what's going on here. Kanye would appreciate this. Okay, it's
45 minutes. Yeah, it is 45 minutes. At least skip the first 55.
the beat go so hard, man. I didn't want to stop. I was so mad
when she stitched to the cops, man. Took too many years of my
life. Thought she would be my wife, man. This just isn't quite
right. Truly thought that we would make it anyway. Man, I was
not prepared for whenever she got scared, man. It's like she
saw a different man in me.
Bad, but she looks like a manity. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, man. She not
a fan of me. Yeah. She cares too much about the vanity. Yeah.
Haters mad. They care about my sanity more than my friends do.
Let's not pretend, dude. Real bad. They paying attention. Maybe
I should just truly mention what I'm feeling and drag everybody
back in like a failure of my part to keep it all concealed.
Y'all hating
in this
no
that's not what I really meant but I suppose. Look, don't know
how this goes from here. Look putting in they in my rear all
day like it was the hallway and they're like how do I find the
spot that really hurts you a lot man that's all that I got I'm
left with
>> you say bad [__] look like a manatee yeah
looking like a manatee yes >> mad
pushing >> he absolutely did >> haters mad at me
>> as they should I am taking care now of my neighborhood
I am actually giving a about the people who surround me, man.
It's like none of this surrounds me anymore. Yeah, this haters
they around me all the time, man. She be like on me cuz they
be slapping my knob. Man, that's not what I meant when I say
she doing a job. Wait, no, it is. Oh, man. Look how her better
focus is. Yeah,
>> Did you just say gang?
bro. The only gang you are repping is rehab. That was a terrible
fade out.
>> stop it. >> That's how it ends. That was just
I can't believe he included that
>> You just organically had that there. That's nuts. All
right, man. That is
>> almost That was amazing. Love this guy. >> That
is so disappointing. >> Is that disappointing?
>> For the five months, >> Post Malone. What's the
other guy? Jack Harlo. They've just got they've got white people
on the internet thinking anybody can rap. >> Uh this guy's
got a vision. Okay. And I I can see it. I love this guy. >> His
vision is bad and a lot of broke back mountain for some reason.
>> Oh, technically we're past the time the stream should
end. But we did not watch the Rose Malay video. Where do I have
the Rose Malay video here? Got to be this one, right? This one.
The end of Brad Tasted music one day ago. Are we going to watch
the Rose Malay review of Brad Taste of Music? Okay, pallet cleanser
quick before we do that and then I think I'll end stream. But
real quick, uh Shu's van is coming together.
So, we had him drilling into
>> the back of a monitor earlier. He's getting better.
Okay, he's getting >> I don't even know, bro. Maybe they'll
refund me. >> Oh my god. Earlier somebody brought up duct
tape. He took their advice. >> It looks like he is just
duct taping this together now. Let's go. >> Finish. That's
That's the entire back of the monitor, isn't it? That's like
a That's like a mount. And that's like the back of the monitor
that's duct taped to the mount, isn't it?
>> The monitor mount. Or at least I mounted the monitor
to the mount. But the monitor still the mount still needs to
be mounted. Now, let's see. Three,
two.
>> Dude, no. He's going to lift it and it's going to fall
off, isn't it? >> Three, two, one. Bro, it's golden.
>> It's working. >> It's going. >> All right,
let me chill. All right, >> dude. You know, you know for
a fact he was looking for a clip right there, right? He He doesn't
want that to work. I feel like there's no way he wanted that
to work. He wanted that to He wanted that monitor to go flying
and shatter so he'd have the clip for looking that I'm starting
to think this guy is just playing a character.
That was an obvious one. >> The thing is, he's still live
right now. Isn't Doesn't this thing start like in 10 hours or
something? >> Yeah. 10 10 11 hours. Yeah. Yeah. About that.
He's also installing Starlink on top of his >> I'm going
to back up. >> On the top of his van. He's going to install
Starlink. >> Oh my goodness. Is he hammering in a >> He's
hammering a screw in with the back
>> What the [__] >> dude? That could
just be a gift on its >> Back up. >> You have this
drill here >> that you're going to have no grip on that
at all. That's crazy.
It's like a support beam type of screw.
>> at some point, but not right now. >> Or is it
meant for this? >> It could break the battery. >> It
is not meant for that. But it can be used for that. >> Can
you get that thing or No, >> I I can't I'll probably break
it, but I could get it out. >> Dude, this guy
This guy is just destroying this van.
Skip forward a little bit. See if he actually gets seized. >> Cuz
he knows it's going to get seized by the police when they realize
what van it >> They realize it's stolen. need is >> does
he actually get this mounted on? >> Go to AutoZone tomorrow
and get metal screws and like silicone and like >> I want
to just put sheet metal screws through this
>> that honestly it would work.
>> if you have sheet metal screws, if you can get them
to fit through here, that would be most optimal. But I think
that's too big >> cuz just look this is I'll just do that.
I'll just charge this and then do that in like the morning, I
guess. >> What's he going to do if it rains? He's just
drilling holes in the top of his van. What is he going to do
if it rains?
>> put an umbrella up there. Duh.
>> Okay. All right. Chewy's on one. Okay. Rose Malay video
real quick. The end of Brad Taste of Music. So, we all remember
Brad came out disavowed Rose Malay. Now she gets the chance to
do the same. >> You are one of my abusers. So, I can damn
right do that to you. I can kick you the out of here for what
the you've done to me. >> You destroyed me. >> What?
How? All I've ever wanted to do is support. Stop lying to me
for once. Look at me in the eyes and stop lying to me.
>> Have you seen how the WNBA is being terrorized by It's
the fourth game in about a week. Someone tossed a rubber cup
on the court. I have seen that. Cherry. You remember the title
you read the other day? The the news article. >> Yeah.
That they banned they banned bags from going against the WNBA
to stop the
>> Oh, what the >> I've heard about this.
That's up. They hit a child in the face with one of the That's
crazy. Alex Stein started that thing, right? Really? >> Why
would somebody bring their child to a WNBA game? That feels cruel.
>> I have no idea.
Why would somebody be at a WNBA game
who doesn't play in the WNBA? That seems pretty >> I know.
Ask Drake. >> I mean, >> look at me and accept what
you have done to me. Do you see what I You me. You promised me
everything. You lied to me.
>> Look at me. The I said that again. Look at me. Tell
me. Tell me. Tell me what the [__] you just said.
Tell me. Get out of my house.
>> Get out of my house. >> I promise you.
Don't do it. Don't do it. Don't. Don't. You're >> You're
I'm You're
concerning things. We're good. Last year, Brad told me that he
was arrested along with some other very concerning things. I
was able to find the arrest record. The reason he told me this
is because he said to me while laughing that no one would believe
me. >> I believe that I had an obligation to put this information
out there. And it was all so bad that I was willing to completely
friendship because I felt like his audience had a right to know
the things that I knew. And I put it all in a video and I didn't
release it. The reason is because I had friends who told me that
I couldn't release it. That Brad was going to kill himself if
I did release it. >> So, I'm the one who sent her these
messages that she >> I'm sorry, who the [__]
was this young >> Uh, this would be probably Brad's friend,
maybe telling her >> delete the Brad video. You are genuinely
so sweet and kind. But I see what you can become if you post
that Brad video. But if you keep going Brad with the uh keep
the Brad video, which you're going to, let's be honest, it's
because you're not as good a person as you think. It's like if
it I was an alcoholic, blah blah blah. You'd be sacrificing Brad
for your ego, which would make you evil. He should delete this
video that she made about Brad. During a Discord call, she told
me that she had no actual intention of releasing this video.
And then I said, "If that's true, delete it." It's like being
a recovering alcoholic and keeping a bottle of wine in your fridge.
Why would you keep it there unless you eventually plan on drinking
it? She ends up deleting it when I finally convince her to do
so. Unfortunately,
she does have a stalker. >> I just got this number from
a really interesting place. Why are you sing over >> You
have all these folders of every single tweet that Rose has ever
made. You claim that someone is sending you all of this, but
I feel like nobody but you would have time to organize all of
that. He was looking for the opportunity to upload that video.
The reason why he couldn't do it before is because she would
have copyright struck it down because it was still on her channel
as unlisted, but because she deleted it, anyone can re-upload
that video and there ain't she could do about it. So that's why
he went ahead and re-uploaded >> People told me not to
>> Wait, couldn't he just re couldn't she just re-upload
it again? The [__] What is this clip? What's this
clip clip? Quick clip about that. He's also installing Starlink
on top of his >> I'm going. >> Thank you very much
for the I We did just watch this. >> The video. So, >> sorry.
I
>> We got to go. >> Now, recently after Brad posted
his video, I have been in contact with him throughout all of
this. >> In fact, I am the reason he deleted that first
video. I informed him that Tina was planning on dropping a response
and that scared him. He says to me, "Okay, I need to get out
of this clearly because he knows how damning that recording is."
I say to him, "She is apparently claiming that you abused her
for 5 years." And he responds with, "Yeah, I took down the video.
I don't need her getting lawyers and airing dirty laundry. The
good news is that I can hide for a bit longer hopefully." And
again, I'm stupid for not realizing how sketchy this looked.
Now Brad told >> Why were they still friends as of two
weeks ago? I don't understand. How the [__] was he
still messaging her two weeks ago? This is weird. >> I
think he recorded a note video. >> I think I'd rather just
end it right now. Yeah. So I said it out loud. I recorded in
20 minutes.
So me and a couple other friends have been talking to him for
like hours pretty much every day trying to convince him not to
kill himself. I basically told him, "Look, just record a short
video apologizing for that video and then leave the internet
entirely for a full year." I just wanted to give him emotional
support. And quite frankly, I just wanted to make sure that the
dude didn't himself. That was my main priority. Now, throughout
our calls, Brad would make some comments about Tina that uh kind
of irked me, but I kind of just chocked it up to the fact that,
you know, due to all this drama going on, he probably has some
feelings about the whole thing. That all changed when on August
4th, he sent me an hourong video of a freestyle that he was doing.
And throughout the video, he talks about Tina, and he just says
some very nasty stuff about her. >> She was letting people
think that I beat her just so that she can stay out of it. Oh
man, I really hope she feels proud of it. Ridiculous. This I
put up with a bad [__] needs to pipe down. So what
do I do? Oh, simply I yell at her. That's just what I do.
I'm just a messenger. Look, a true story. I was yelling at the
Yeah. What you do for me? Well, ruin my life. The bad looking
for some evidence. Look, is it ever this? Is it ever as bad as
they say it is? See, that's what this got me think. I was so
mad when she stitched to the cap. Man, I was not prepared for
whenever she got scared. Man, it's like she saw a different man
in me. Oh, bad [__] but she looks like a manity.
They coming after me. Assault and battery is what they blame.
They say that I've been
running away from the truth. And I commit assault and battery
against my girl. You know the one I love, the one who's my entire
world. And she believes this. don't know how she's deceived herself
into this. >> And again, despite everything, I was never
going to leak this. I was never going to talk about this because
quite frankly, it's none of my business. It's a personal situation
between two people and I kind of realized that I should just
stay out of it. That all changed when Tina decided to release
the audio. Now, the reason I'm making this video is because when
Brad >> does look like they removed the beat from that,
okay, >> he lied about what was recorded on that video.
He basically made it seem like he just said, "Get the out of
my house." But like in the video, he talks about making up to
the cops >> without being a sarcastic.
Look at me in the eyes and tell me the truth in the eyes. Tina,
>> you are >> I'm going to call the police. I will
get you out of here. I will make a story of I will get you out
of here.
>> I will say my partner has been emotionally abusive and
I have asked her to leave many times. That's what I'm going to
tell them. >> That's so >> I'm going to call and
you will destroy
>> You will do anything. >> I just want to be able
to think quietly while I brush my dogs. I just want to be able
to quietly reflect on my life while I brush my dogs. >> Okay.
How much that's like crazy overlap with Amaran and Nick, isn't
there? Like I I can't be the only one who hears it. Let me take
care of my dogs. >> Dogs without you asking what I'm thinking
about and prying it out of me and thinking you're entitled to
know what I'm thinking about. You're not >> I'm not even
your partner. De
>> You're not treating me like a partner. >> You
look like one of those freaks on the interrogation videos. >> I
can't look at your >> Every single thing you're doing is
full
>> You're literally acting like the criminals there.
I have trouble with
Oh, no you don't. Tina, >> you are a lying, manipulative
person. >> In trouble, >> you need to get out of
my house.
>> He's got he's got the Tucker Carlson cadence going.
And you need to get out of my house.
>> I do. >> I am going to call the cops if you don't
stop lying to me, Tina, right now. This is it. >> Like,
it's just so blatantly abusive. I honestly was completely shocked
and horrified. I mean, this is somebody that I have known since
2017 and throughout all of my years of knowing this person. I
have had this constant battle with myself of wanting to expose
things about him because he keeps doing that concerns me. Back
in 2017, all the people that he was originally friends with,
like most of them have turned against him because of his behavior.
And I was the first person to really call him out. I know a lot
of people afterwards started to realize some of the things that
I'd already realized. >> He claims that she's using misleading
screenshots to push her victim complex and that he has never
had any less respect for anyone than I do her. All she said is
that Brad should be careful what he says because of his audience.
I have a playlist of all of the mental health videos from like
2018 2019. I might release that now. And it's really shocking
to me that it took people this long to kind of realize that like
he got a problem. If I were to call him out, I were to say anything.
People would be like, "Well, Road, who the [__] are
you to say anything?" I think Brad knows this, too. In fact,
it's the reason why he's talked to me so much over these past
few days because everybody else that he's talked to, they want
nothing to do with him after everything has come out. And Brad
would just tell me how horrible they were, how awful of friends
they were that they would betray him and all that. And I comforted
him. But after seeing that video, I just can't look at him in
the same way again. And it just sucks that when like I tried
to speak up before because like the videos on YouTube, you can
find it. I was spot on about everything regarding the arrest.
I had all the details. I knew everything. And everyone was telling
me that I shouldn't reset it because I would be a bad person
because I would ruin him. And so when he rekindled with me, I
thought that it was very good. I would be a positive influence
in his life that I was lucky to be his friend. That's how I saw
it. But it's like if a dude is only talking to me because his
other friends have left and due to his disgusting behavior, that's
not a true friend. You know, I shouldn't be okay with that. I
should have more self-respect. And when somebody's exposed to
doing [__] things and then all of a sudden wants
to act all buddy buddy with me. No, I'm sorry. I can't do that.
I can't [__] do that. The thing that hurts the most
though is like I do genuinely still hope he gets help. Like I
hope he doesn't [__] kill himself. But like in the
call, he uses Does Rose only exist in the capacity to try to
kill Brad once in a while. It seems that way. I have no idea
why he was talking to her on the 26th of July.
That's like two weeks ago >> as manipulation. Like he just
blatantly >> You give me another reason. Make me want to
get a knife and myself. Please. Please don't hurt yourself. Tina
goes on. You wouldn't stop me. Brad says, "Yes, I would." Tina
goes on. Do it. Watch me. I'm dead anyways. >> And it makes
me question everything. I guess at the end of the day, I pretty
much just learned that like I need to learn to trust my gut.
When I have feelings about a person, like the thousands of comments
that people have made telling me that I was being awful to Brad,
that I did this to Brad, it influenced my perception and I wanted
to give him more chances because of that. And it's like when
Brad talked to me, he would talk about how his trust was betrayed
because she recorded him. But hearing the recording, it's like
I understand why she recorded him. He has this influence and
power. If she didn't record that, no one would ever believe her.
And that's what makes that's what's so disgusting about all of
this. When I spoke up about him, nobody listened to me. Listen,
I've made horrible tweets. What Brad did was abuse. I am a victim
of abuse. And it sucks because I know people are going to think,
"Oh, look at Rose trying to get in on the drama." I legitimately
was not ever going to post about this ever. This changes things
for me. That video he posted, he did that on his own. He didn't
tell anybody he was making that video. That was a really stupid
idea. And I told him, what you don't understand is I called Brad
hours ago. Hours. And he told me first thing in that call that
he dropped a video and I was like, "Wait, why?" He said he was
going to be offline for a year. And I told him it was a really
stupid idea. And he was trying to argue with me on why it was
actually good. But honestly, at this point, I'm glad. I'm glad
that all this is out there. Like, wait, >> wait. She posted
this video yesterday and said that she called him hours ago,
>> So, she's not just talking to him two weeks ago. She's
talking to him like two days ago, right? >> Yeah. Apparently.
Yeah. I don't know why. Why do people keep talking about the
Rosem Chud DMs?
>> I don't know what they are.
I just know that I've been on a panel with this girl and she
was like in the workplace because misogyny actually feels very
gender affirming for her >> and I just I don't even know
what to do with that.
>> Like when men talk down to them makes her feel like
a woman and Okay, >> it's actually over. I don't think
YouTube at all. He can't come back to YouTube. And in fact, I'm
gonna show you something else. I saw this on Twitter, right?
And I tried to ask the girl for more information. This girl that
claims to have gone to school with Bradley is claiming that he
stalked a girl. And I checked like she's from the state that
Brad is from. I can't confirm this allegation, but like
>> dude, what uh yeah, this person did say once that they
were from the state that Brad's from. So, you know, I can't confirm
this, but seems pretty consistent. He He probably stalked this
person. Talk my boyfriend's ex and would look through her window.
He would follow her and park outside her house. I had to share
cuz what the do I never want to see that >> in addition
to all of this, I'm just so done. And I can't believe like I
made so many excuses for this guy. I I'm so mad at myself because
like this happens time and time again with me, you know? I get
treated like and so I just assume that other people are wrongly
treated and I want to be their advocate. I want to help them.
I want to help them make good choices and then like people get
exposed for awful [__] and it's just like I don't
want to be around people like that. I need people in my life
who are going to motivate me to be better, people in my life
who respect me. So yeah, this is coming from somebody who's a
friend. I can't believe this [__] And one last thing,
I'm really sorry to Tina. I wanted to see these clips because
I was planning on like doing this expose. I wanted to talk to
Tina. I wanted to know. And had I seen these clips, I wouldn't
have been out here offending this guy. The reason I wanted to
see that is because like if this is somebody I'm going to associate
with, I want to know what really went down. I'm sorry for bothering
her. You know, she happened to be in a live stream where they
were talking me. But when I say like I truly had no idea like
what was in that audio. Brad made it seem like to me like that
the audio was just him yelling like he was just telling her to
get out of his house. But like he was not honest to me. He lied
to me. Suicide again. Care about me are converting into people
who don't. I just want to be [__] seen. None of those
positive comments mean anything if the world thinks I abuse Tina.
She's going full swing attack mode. I'm just going to I'm just
going to blank for a bit and hope she changes her mind. >> I
don't know why I believed him considering everything. At the
end of the day, I just hope you all learned something from this.
Be careful who you're supporting out there. >> Also, I
think my ex once showed me a Jason Aldine song and I think I
remember within the first 10 seconds was I just remember hearing
about 10 seconds of it and being like, "Nope." And I ran off.
I think she was very saddened by that. I think she was very offended,
but I can't give it any higher because of her. Um, again, I don't
really watch my panic videos that much. She says, "I never come
back to this video cuz it hurts to watch, but it's definitely
one of my funniest videos. Like, it's entertaining. I don't want
to rank it any higher cuz of her though." Yeah. Adara, you know
what I'm saying? But I had my ex in it and I had to take it down.
Well, I didn't have to take it down, but let's just say
uh let's just say that some bridges are best left burnt, you
know? I mean, for crying out loud, I had my ex cried at Panic
at the Disco, so I mean, you know, luckily I'm not out of that,
but still. Yeah. >> What about Bradley? I'm really glad
that he's taking time off of YouTube to reflect on himself. I
think it's great that he's working on some of his emotional problems.
He generally seems like he's gotten a lot better. I just hope
he's okay. >> What?
Why do we include >> Why do we include this in the >> What's
wrong What's wrong with crying out panic at the disco? It sounded
pretty sad when that like chimed in or >> Uh-huh. Okay.
>> You know that one. >> On that note, I don't know
any Panic at the Disco songs now. But >> yes, you do. Everybody
knows Panic at the Disco.
I chimed in with a
Come on. >> Oh, no. I do know I know the song you were
just doing 19 years ago. Really?
No way.
>> I don't think I know this song.
>> It's got 400 million views. How do I know the song?
>> No, no, no, no. I know this part.
>> Yeah. Okay. Okay. Okay, I know the song. I know this
song.
>> All right. All right. >> Yeah, I remember. >> Dude,
that's such an old That's crazy old. Holy moly.
19 years ago. >> But it's so good. >> Jesus. 2006
was 19 years ago. Oh, boy. Oh, boy. All right. Uh, that's it
for us, guys. I think we're we're done for
>> W stream bad.
>> Wream W bad
medieval gays. All right.
Yeah. Be back tomorrow. Might try to be here early for scavenger
hunt. I'm not totally sure yet. Did you see Tape's gift? No.
What? Oh, dude. This is This is some incredible stuff. >> That's
crazy that he doesn't know how to screw works. >> I don't
know what he knows something about things. >> You actually
make it so it doesn't grip onto anything.
That's crazy.
Like I think he thinks that if he gets further down it'll slide
into the grooves or something like it's getting caught on something
and then it can get into the grooves and it'll actually like
torque itself once you >> I don't think there's he's thinking
anything. Is there a single thought going on in his brain when
he does this? >> He's a incredible guy. Incredible guy.
All right, let's see. Anybody online? Rally online apparently.
I'll raid rally. All right, have a good night guys. Going to
raid rally. We'll talk to you all tomorrow. We'll be back. Thanks
for the stream. W stream content. You can see why Zena likes
him. True. All right, we'll see you guys later. Raiden out. Bye-bye.
>> Good night.